before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification bell the way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos as you
guys know if you have watched two or
more of my videos and you do not
subscribe we have beef okay beef people
while you're at it sign up for our
memberships to
have exclusive behind-the-scenes content
and the second half of our stream today
is members only so if you guys want to
be a part of the chat for the whole
stream sign up for our membership so
today we have a huge panel but a lovely
panel so we're gonna go around everyone
say your name your age your relationship
status and where you're from starting
with you
hiya name is alexander age 27
relationship status single bachelor
hey my name's s
um i'm 41 a relationship status single
from london
i'm donna and i'm 39 relationship status
single and i'm from london
i'm alicia 25 25 28. relationship status
single and from london
my name's alice i'm 27 single um and i'm
also from london
yeah miri mister why always me
35 single
london trinidad
um i'm terence from south london um
uh and i'm in a relationship
[Music]
hi my name's rosie i'm 24 and i'm in a
relationship
hi guys my name is jordan i'm 28 and i'm
in a relationship and i'm from southeast
london
okay guys so today we are talking about
hypergamy so i'm just curious um for the
ladies on the panel have you guys heard
of hypergamy
yes yes i have now you have
monkey points before today not before
today i googled it just before coming
home okay so hypergamy is the action of
marrying or forming a sexual
relationship with a person of a superior
sociological or educational background
so the idea is that when women date we
want to date up in some way whether it's
they make more money than us they're
more educated than us or
they're better looking than us and this
is just when you survey women on what
they want in a man
and what researchers have come to find
out is that 100 of women want 20 of men
and so the reason a lot of times girls
say things like men are trash men are
the problem that sort of thing men
always cheat is because we're all dating
the same ones
yeah and and some people think it's even
smaller some people say five percent but
i just say 20 on like the high end wow
yeah and is that overall yeah well it's
the way they find this out is through
dating app data
so there's only available the women that
want to date up there's only twenty
percent
of yeah available so i'll give you an
example um
how many of you guys wanna do a guy over
six foot
no five ten
what's your height requirement go ahead
i don't think i have a height actually i
don't want to date anyone five five so
okay let's do five eleven five eleven
okay i'm barely five one so okay you got
the whole you got the whole anything up
here's a bonus
i'm five six so i tend to want somebody
around my height or taller okay yeah i
mean i'm a fellow shorty so i've never
really had to think about it so
the reason i bring this up is because
most girls when i ask them height wise
they want to date their height or taller
and so that's just
an example of how women use hypergamy
so mike
yeah yeah you see right
interesting
so my question is
a common complaint that i hear from men
is that women have too high of standards
when
are standards too high and i want to go
around starting there
um
i don't agree with that statement okay
go ahead i just think
a lot a lot of dudes are weak and so
instead of rising to the competition
they'll rather tell women hey man you
should just want less but from what i
see in the dating game
the characteristics or the qualities
women want aren't
our things you can develop
you know some of the best seducers in
history maybe neil strauss who wrote the
game he's a bold 40 year old man and he
got the most tale of anyone in new york
so the idea that it's about being six
foot in a millionaire is completely
untrue and these guys know this because
they complain about chad and tyrone and
chad and terrell is never like some rich
guy is it
you know so um yeah but those qualities
of being kind being charismatic being
sophisticated in some way being athletic
you guys can hit the gym you can learn
how to talk to women you can be more
patient you know you could respect her
more in certain ways so i don't agree
that the standards are too high
okay go ahead
um
the standard's too high i think
i think women have
a lot of expectations
when it comes to men and i think
sometimes those expectations aren't
always realistic
um
i do think
that men obviously do think that women
think too highly of themselves sometimes
but
i think that's the them problem to be
fair i think they need to i think they
need to up their game in regards to
being a lot more um understanding when
it comes to women
and yeah that's just that's my opinion
okay go ahead
um
yeah i'd say the same and women's
expectations more than standards
and
and
kind of loss of words
no yeah
i don't think women's standards are too
high i agree more or less with
everything and you said that
men have to kind of
come to an understanding of what men
have to be more i'd say more i'd say
women's expectations are more on an
emotional level
than a money level
for me anyway they want they want like a
guy that's emotionally available exactly
yeah for me
it's
i'd rather someone that was emotionally
available than someone that had a lot of
money okay what about you i think it
kind of depends if you're looking at the
talk a little closer
it depends if you're looking at the real
world or through dating apps because on
dating apps it's easy to say yeah i want
x y and z but actually when you meet
people
naturally you'll find that a lot of that
kind of goes out the window and you're
happy as long as you just have that
connection or the basic fundamentals
with that individual which comes down to
like the emotional intelligence and
things like that as opposed to saying
okay what's your salary how tall are you
what do you do okay go ahead
i would say that there's a difference
between being selective and having high
standards i think that women and it's if
you look at dating app data it's very
well understood that the women are
they will they will swipe less freely
they'll be they'll think more about
their swiping and they'll probably swipe
right less often whereas men if you're
going stereotype will just you know get
they will play the numbers game
um but i wouldn't say that's because
women are looking for a man of a certain
height and a certain income i think
they're looking for someone who they
click with more and there just seems to
be a phenomena where men seem to play
the numbers game more okay what do you
think
i think a lot that was a lot to wrap him
all right firstly yeah
okay so
all right the 80 of men that we're
talking about
you have to understand
that they're completely invisible
we're talking about ram roop from
chicken cottage we're not you know what
i'm trying to say
right so when when we're starting we're
starting at a basis where you're already
oh this is tyrone he's already six foot
i already know what he does you don't
need to ask him what his career is you
already know he's so i wanted someone
that's nice is because you want someone
that's nice that already has
the fits the narrative that the person
of what you want
you're not going to be attracted to
someone that you're not attracted to or
doesn't fit your criteria and women in
the west criteria is very high
and they all have to they all seem to
have the same criteria they all want the
same type of guy
even though they would love to admit
that they don't want the same type of
guy
maybe it doesn't work out with the right
type of guy and now you move on to
another guy that you you don't feel as
happy that you are with that guy
when really and truly you wish that guy
that you really want was like the guy
that you're with now
is more what happens when you say like
out on the road that you meet people no
people women have to settle and they do
settle when they hit the wall they
settle when they've been through too
much stress they settle when they need
money problems they settle when when
they when they that you know what this
guy's just on my case so much let me
just
all right
yeah that's when they settle but they
they're really trying to get that main
guy and if that main guy came when they
are in a relationship with that the guy
that they settled
hi purging me bro they're gone no i
don't know
what do you class as that main guy of
curiosity
you know the guy
okay i'll give you i'll give you an
example okay
most girls that i know
even there's one guy that they just like
really deeply loved right and they loved
more than all of their other exes and
they could be dating the next guy or the
next guy or the next guy but if that ex
calls they're back
i disagree
i think
i think that comes with age okay
i think um obviously i'm 40. mm-hmm one
sorry
i'm 41 and um
i don't go back
i go forward am i ever going back in my
young i've gone back for sex
that's it
so i wouldn't ever look at that person
as to have a relationship with if i
haven't you know been seen anyone and
i want to have sex then i might go back
to that person or i did go back to that
person in the past but
yeah do you think it's your choice
of course it's my choice
you think a man wanting to have a
relationship with you is your choice
yeah i do
so what do you think will separate the
man that just wants to sleep with you
from the man that wants that
relationship with you
that's a very good question
but i don't know it's an individual
thing isn't it i mean
i can probably count on one hand the
amount of men who just wanted to sleep
with me
so
yeah every girl wants to sleep with you
no but i mean that have i mean i mean
we all know that when when a man meets a
woman it's initially you know attraction
isn't it like
obviously women have the same thing as
well it's not it's not just men by the
way that's not the same um well i can
look at a man and think oh i'd just love
to sleep with him but he's not i
wouldn't really want to be with him for
the rest of my life so we do have that
as well
yeah but do you get attached when it
happens i don't know
so do you think that's because you've
passed the stage where you can get
attached
no i've never been attached you've never
been attached through sex no never never
neither
never
you've never been in a long-term
relationship
but it wasn't because of the sex and the
sex are you being has the sex kept us
there i'm saying that i've never been
whipped
man i'm saying i'm not saying whipped
i'm saying you've never grown to love a
man through sex
ever
no i don't think i have i've loved
someone's sex
because someone is good in bed no way
i'm not saying you'll stay only because
he's good in bed but that's typically
how women bond we release a hormone
during sex that men don't which is
oxytocin so basically like women fall in
love through orgasms as like as weird as
weird as that is but like
yeah like because we release a hormone
that they don't mm-hmm but as somebody
that so when i
have had a lot of long-term
relationships i'm like a relationship
person
and i'll often wait for quite a while
before i have sex with the guy so i want
to date them first i want to get to know
what's about see if there's a connection
or anything like that and i can also go
through phases of not sleeping with them
because i think most of the intimacy
doesn't come through sex it comes
through spending time with that person
building a connection with that person
and making memories and things i'm not
i'm not saying that's the only way you
can bond with a guy i'm just saying
women bond through sex in a way that men
don't i think and and you can you can
think it whatever but i'm saying like
study after study will tell you women
bond in a way that men don't maybe maybe
i'm talking to four exceptions i don't
know so is that is that why so men do
not bond through sex we do they they do
but not in the same way they they get
they release a hormone that makes them
territorial that's why like
some guys you know they'll sleep with a
girl and they'll move on and they'll
still be mad when the next guy hits
because they released a hormone that
made them territorial
yeah so like we're talking about sexual
energy like this yeah like like like
[ __ ] i'm saying women fall in love
through sex men fall in love through
quality time and loyalty i must be a man
then
i want to just go back to that how what
do you consider a long-term relationship
um so my first was six years old
how old are you i'm twenty-eight
twenty-eight yeah you're gone uh my last
one's gonna be three years now
three years okay and then i had like a
one-year one
so you had three long-term relationships
and you and you said that you you had
sex and you took it away because you
because it wasn't about no it was one of
those things where before i slept with
them that connection was kind of built
first like i had to trust that person
and know that um it's not just going to
be physical there's going to be
something more there right that's what
that's what i thought you meant but i'm
saying that's for you
a man i would want to have sex with you
the moment i see you like it's like it's
not i don't i want to build a connection
and i want to get to know her
the more you make me wait the less i
probably want to um
that's a bit harsh to say
the the longer you make me wait the more
i want to be spiteful yeah
yeah i want to be spanish
i want to be spiteful because you gave
it to that guy for in on the one night
stand he wasn't he wasn't crap to you
yeah but me you saw me coming along and
you thought you know what
you know what i was like
yeah
like okay i'm gonna be proper this time
i'm gonna i'm gonna keep it close i'm
gonna be proper and he's thinking wait
hold on a minute like michael got it on
day one like you trying to make me wait
four months yeah all right wait till
four months is done and i've pre and
i've pressed you
now we'll see when i've got my post not
clarity if i want to stay firstly
so i've also spoken to a lot of guys who
say that when they sleep with somebody
straight away they tend to lose a little
bit of respect for them it depends and
then they no longer really look at them
as a long-term partner because they
thought okay this was really easy so how
many other individuals is she's sleeping
i think the question is is it genuine
because the thing is like what he's
referring to is a girl that gives and i
don't i don't know you maybe you've
never had a one night stand that's fine
but i'm saying well he's referring what
he's referring to is girls that give it
up on the first night for some guys and
then make another guy wait and so it's
kind of like to him well i had to put
all this investment where the other guy
just got it for free so it's really
frustrating to men because they feel
like you're not really attracted to them
because you gave it to the other guy
isn't it a compliment to them though
exactly
it shows that the woman is taking you
seriously perhaps no i think i think
that's like a woman's point of view yeah
please wait a few months until i feel
like sleeping with you it's a compliment
that's the assumption i'm making you
wait because i like myself yeah i think
women have a fear if they genuinely like
a guy
of
them being rejected okay so you're
saying the reason why you make me wait
is because if you think you give it to
me early i'm not going to respect you as
much as if you made me wait potentially
but then you disrespected me by giving
someone else no chance to wait why are
you doing your business comparing
yourself
because we're men we're we're very
territorial we're very competitive we're
very com
i don't want you i don't want to have
intercourse with a girl that that's well
i don't want to be taking a woman
seriously when she's had um intercourse
with my friends yes see men can't undo
their biology yeah and and the thing is
um men are but they're predispositioned
to be repulsed by women that sleeps
around so and the reason is because
historically they had to ensure
paternity so if they were wiping
basically like wiping a hoe back in the
day they could be raising a kid that's
not theirs and even though we have birth
control nowadays you can't undo their
hard wiring so and the data supports it
because women that
have sex with one person and that's
their husband have an 80 chance of being
in a happy marriage and if they have
sleep with more than five people that
drops down to 20 after 10 years
wow but is that not contradictory to
what he just said about if you make
somebody wait then they kind of become
spiteful and but then you're saying
no it depends how you make me no but i'm
saying like it depends if it's genuine
it's did the girl did the girl sleep
with 20 dudes and then make him way or
is she a virgin and making him wait
because she's a virgin like there's two
very different ways to go about it but
when you kind of start dating somebody
you don't necessarily discuss your sex
life with that individual anyway so like
for example how would you know that i've
slept with x y and zed i would not get
to know you and i would know how because
okay you know woman's intuition you know
that feeling you get when it's like now
this guy is cheating a man has an
intuition as well he could smell the
hole yeah
you could smell it it could be like no
just like not
she'll be like i've never done this
before and then right back what does it
mean
she could have just watched the porn to
get herself ready
you don't believe it
i mean your your woman intuition isn't
always correct but
the majority of the time at some point
it's on point so you know i might not
every girl i would second guess i'll be
like you know what i'm going with my
intuition not every time i'll be right
but majority of the times i'm right
because there's certain signals that
girls give off
when they tend to be more persecute um
um signals women give up about being
more promiscuous yeah i'm very open
sexually and i grew up in
a family that was very like sex wasn't a
taboo subject my daughters i speak very
openly with freely with them about sex
and
i had slept with one person from i was
50 until i was 33 in a whole 18-year
relationship
and i was very open sexually but
i find that
some people will look at that as being
oh that you can openly talk about sex
and orgasms and things that they would
think
that's
she must be promiscuous because she can
talk about sex or she she loves me you
said no no i'm not i'm i didn't say it
no no no i said science i'm saying to
you
that's i think sometimes the signs might
be
misconstrued because absolutely i think
men think that women being open talking
about sex
and
talking about orgasms being very like
sometimes smoking to sometimes men are
wrong you're right like sometimes they
don't guess correctly but i just like
the point is that when men
realize that a girl has been ran through
it repulses them
and they can't help it it's their
biology yeah the same way women want a
guy that's taller than us because we
wanted a guy to protect us that's our
biology but we're in control of body
count men aren't in control of height
yeah i agree
so
like you don't think okay
if your friend has done something yeah
that she wasn't supposed to do can't you
just feel it on her like she's just done
something like i like
i you can't put your finger on it yeah
but it's something about your friend
like no you did something you did
something with him and it's like that
intuition that men has when you've been
around enough women to know like this
that there's just like triggers that's
like wait hold on i've seen i've seen
that before okay i'll i'll stop and i
wouldn't immediately um
give her the um i'll give her the
benefit of the doubt and be like okay
that was just one sign and then i see
another one it's like
oh it's starting to compile now so when
it's compiled now of certain things that
you look out for as a man to know what
like a promiscuous woman is not
necessarily the same as a woman that's
abstaining no i i hear what you're
saying because i mean i've met men and i
thought wow
like you you as you said about the
protection i'm very i'm a man's man
and i've initially thought yeah and then
saw wow
you're not about that life
and i've do you know the same way you're
saying you can smell a hoe it's like i
can smell a [ __ ]
like
so yeah i get what you're saying like
it's like you could tell like this guy's
faking it he's not really he's not
really really bad
he ain't alpha like yeah he's pretending
like you don't he does he says the right
things yeah but you could just tell it
the bucket no no
so that's the intuition that men are
that men could see in girls and they're
like wait hold on i'm not gonna let her
know that i know i'm gonna sleep with
her first and then i was just gonna
ghost or i'm gonna go with her friend or
i'm gonna
do you guys i'm just gonna um keep on
sleeping with her and not give her a
relationship i'm going
to say he would do things other than
make you his wifey to be walking on road
with you holding hands so everyone else
could see yeah but then if we make you
wait that's an issue as well
it depends who if you're all right if
you've had um intercourse with someone
in the scene
london is a very small place and a big
place at the same time please be
guaranteed that i know at least three
people that you've
you've
not necessarily slept with but you was
talking to or you was doing things with
if i could tell by the caliber of guy
that you're around what you're saying
and i'm speaking to these guys because
men talk to each other on a you like man
just needs to give another guy a little
wink like
that's you mighty like you know says hey
girls they do it as well yeah we do i'm
saying girls give girls the look like
men do things to let men know h don't go
there that's me so so just to understand
you're either the girl that you're going
to end up with has either got to be a
saint that's not slept around and makes
you wait
or
if she's got an open sex life unless she
has sex with you straight away she's not
good enough either so what is your name
you're trying to put me in a corner
without continually i'm trying to
understand what it is
i'll make you understand
if you are accustomed to sleeping around
yeah and then you find that one guy that
you're really interested in want to make
him think that i'm a good girl and he's
he's going to like me i'm going to put
my best foot forward and i'm going to
make him wait and do that he already
knows no no no no i already know what
you're on
i've already seen the whole play already
i'm not coming to you ma'am you have an
only fan yeah like you know what i'm
trying to say like i've don't think the
first time i'm coming to you is the
first time i've seen you i've already
got the play oh what's what's maria
saying okay all right all right what did
you not do the thing yeah what mine was
that okay well she's on that yeah all
right say no more sam okay let me let me
hold her maria when i see maria hi maria
you're right you're so beautiful i love
you and i'm saying god's angel i love
you so much look in the eyes and talk to
you in your ears and whisper and stuff
i'll make you think i'm like you know
what i'm saying like i'm i'm not being
genuine but i'm being genuine if you get
what i'm saying i'm interested but i'm
not going to take you as seriously
you could tell me from a guy's point of
view you want to be the guy that she
breaks rules for yeah like she made
everyone else wait but she slept with
you right away and you're not the guy
she's doing it for is it nice but then
on the other hand
is it say that again isn't it nice to do
the opposite as well though like maybe
she slept around a load of guys but she
wants to take it slow with you because
she really likes
her want to hear from every guy in this
room is that nice
no
i didn't hear what you said she said if
you do the opposite she sleeps with
everyone and takes it slow with you i
want to hear from everyone in the room
wait if she's wife material surely i
don't get that what do you mean
isn't it nice to have rules broken for
you
so if a woman sleeps around a lot yeah
yeah then she meets you and she's like
right i wanna i wanna get him to be my
husband i wanna take things slow yeah
isn't that a sign to you that she really
likes you and is invested so what if she
likes me i don't care if she really
likes me it's not well she's not gonna
be one thing to do with me liking you
i've i've already disqualified you
because i know what you're like but you
know what i think
so you say that you would your friend
would give you the lowdown yeah she's at
home and then you're gonna buckle and
say yeah why go on maria um let's go out
on a date but really all you want to do
is smash no not date who's the date wow
well it's like whether you want whether
it's a smash date or a dinner day or
whatever you want to smash but then
you're not being transparent so then
because you're not telling that you just
want to smash no but a lot of girls like
he doesn't take them out on a date he
doesn't treat them like a girlfriend and
then they sleep together and then she's
mad
because he doesn't wipe her but he never
was he never they weren't dating
intentionally ever anyway i never told
her i want to be your wife i want you to
be my wife i didn't say that i'm just
chilling with you and we happen to have
intercourse i'm not taking it seriously
i don't understand why why is it so bad
for a man to be sexually
active as much as a woman sexually
active and have the freedom to be
sexually active
and not only that
you see really it isn't it isn't that's
right
because i'm not saying you're not
allowed to be sexually active i'm just
saying you can't be sexually active with
me i hate what you're saying i hit like
okay that's not what you want to write
but i think like what you just said was
the total reversal of what we know is
true like it's okay for you guys to be
hoes but as soon as a woman has slept
around
yeah it's because men and women are
different it's a double standard no it's
definitely that's what i'm saying
you said it like in terms of what
because if if if your girlfriend's man
slept around you're not going to be like
it's all right darling like it's men no
i'm not right so there we go so let's
not make it out like i was i was brought
up by a man i was raised by my dad so i
was instilled early into me that what
what we think of women who [ __ ] around
because after my mum passed away all my
dad did was [ __ ] around
so i soon got to see how women that
[ __ ] up got treated so
i knew that from the start and i
wouldn't be happy for my daughters to
sleep around that is what's instilled in
me all right it's like this a male goal
digger
a male gold digger yeah is looked at
worse than a female gold digger as in
that show what was that show called 100
um
the thing that girls do every single day
on this earth like he was dishonest
every day what were you talking about he
was the
the tinder swindler yeah how was this on
it how women are just homicide
he was like yeah he was saying that old
people coming to get him and people are
trying to
like there are entire industries built
on women scamming men online because one
in three men under the age of 30 hasn't
done sex in the past year or is a virgin
one in three men yeah so
so there are entire industries built off
of women doing webcam and that sort of
thing getting money and extracting money
off of men that's how andrew tate made
his money that's why he's a
multi-multi-millionaire and nobody bats
and i nobody cares when it's a guy and
they say you should have known better
but with the women they get a whole
goddamn documentary yeah but they're
they're getting something out of it it's
a transaction
no no because they'll sell him the dream
that's what they do and like andrew tate
like breaks this down where they will
literally
convince these guys that one day they're
going to meet one day they're going to
sleep together one day one day one day
and like this happens every day no one
cares the women's girl watching disney
so
maybe
maybe maybe the girls in the tinder
swindler should stop watching disney
absolutely
like everyone
but i'm saying people did fundraisers
they were raising money for these women
yeah but to me i'm like that was your
own damn fault why on earth would anyone
donate to that and that's what i would
say to the guys too but for the men
they do it yeah like they don't nobody
cares the women people care
when your heart is hungry you eat so i
want to ask you something ladies
how would you not feel if males
exploited women the way how women
exploit males in the porn industry in
terms of this
all right we're getting there now so
let's get there so we know that this man
at home is sitting down lonely he has no
sex he hasn't he's has no female
interaction but you're using that as
your tool to get money out of him okay
is that not exploitation i've i i only
watch porn from with men i don't know oh
say corn say corn corn corn yeah i only
watch corn with them
and made and female so how are we
exploiting because no i'm saying in
terms of like only fans in terms of like
yeah
um um chat obey i'm talking about all
these websites where they have girls
it's it's a website where girls sit down
in front of the cam and they're like
you're right i'm lonely guy four five
six yeah send me send me some dough i'll
show you my feet
like i'm your best friend i'm saying
this exploitation happens
what do you mean it's exploitation is it
just that right it's dangerous
is it exploitation or is it just an
exchange of services
can you hear that right okay so you
could argue that's what the tinder
swindler did yes
they got to go on a private jet what
does the guy get for feedback
i never watch this so i can't comment
but he did get taken to court right
didn't he actually like con them which
is slightly different yeah they just
i would say slightly different because
he's met these individuals in person
he's built a rapport with them he's he's
actually thought allowed them to think
that they are getting to know him as a
person like if i was to
there were some individuals that thought
they were engaged to this man they they
physically been together okay okay but
so so the same way like the way you're
talking is literally how andrew tate
describes how the women need to talk to
the men
like i'm telling you word for word
basically and so just like i think it's
delusional of those men to think that a
woman like that is gonna take them
seriously i think it's a delusional of
those women 100 average average looking
girls to think that a multi-millionaire
is going to take you seriously is there
not a difference when there's a
um web screen
put in the way because the chats that we
were talking about that's kind of you're
paying for something virtually as
opposed to something with the tinder
swindler where that's in person you're
meeting these people and building no i'm
that can i can i give you a stat so um
the results revealed that 23 percent of
women have engaged in a foodie foodie
call on an occasional basis with a
number of them believing it was socially
acceptable the second study analyzed 357
female participants and further
discovered that 33 percent of women
would go on a date purely for a free
mail right so this happens like every
day
face to face so you you like when you
said you make him wait
there's nothing stopping you from
actually having sex with him on day one
well it comes down to my own values i
know when whenever you you're ready
obviously
after a couple more dates after i've
spent my money on you after uh after
wait hold on because
you potentially after the three months
could say you know what i actually don't
like you
but i've already invested in you for
three months well isn't that dating
for for for you that's dating for me
that's an expense but why are you
assuming that it's an expense because
you know what i want that the mail is
paying no no you know what i want what
do you want
so what does every man want from a woman
that he's going on
no no no i'm not saying that she's not
saying that you have to just give it up
he's talking about there's two different
types of girls right there's a type of
girl that makes you wait because it's
genuine and there's a girl that makes
you wait because she bit she's been ran
through and she's afraid of getting ran
through again and it's just completely
different to guys i think both are
justified to make somebody wait i think
it could be justified to a female
perspective but that's not how men view
it because they value chastity
they value purity and so it's like
you're you're the product right and it's
like you're upping the price that they
have to pay to get the product without
adding any extra value it's like you're
a lower value you might have learned a
few tricks
you said you said it perfectly it's all
about choice though isn't it it's as
simple as that you have a choice if you
don't want to stay with someone who is a
hoe go nathan you do have fun yeah but
you're the is the deception so you're
saying i should be able to deceive and
you have the choice whether or not you
want to be deceived or not doesn't it
doesn't mean that the deceiver is right
to deceive what is that
men deceive every diet exactly but does
it make it right that they deceive
everything that's not that's not no it
doesn't make it wise
but a very small percentage of men even
have the option to deceive women again
one in three men under 30 they haven't
had sex in the past year
or are virgins
so that's what i'm saying the reason
women like say phrases like that is
because we're all sleeping with the same
guys it's a very small percentage of men
that can even get girls
yeah i i i really find that shocking i
thought everybody could get a girl
you just go to some of them clubs on a
friday saturday night they're out there
well those are the guys that cannot
those are the guys that can afford to
make it to the club just guys i don't
even need to go in
the tube
i i think else i'll give it i see i
think you're where where are these women
giving out
can you name an exact time on location
even the most like out there man he
still has to go through like
hoodles and hoops to play with women
even even that 20 guy still has to be on
point and do things right and be in the
right place at the right time say the
right things be the right physique um
take her to the right place say the
right things to her friends there's a
lot of things that i'm hard for you guys
it is so hard because you don't have no
expectations you could just come with
yours what do women have to do to get
sex we just have to exist
i'm not saying it's your fault but i'm
saying like i empathize with men because
it's a lot harder for them to even feel
like desired they have to go through all
of this work to even have girls
interested in them where we just exist
because we have such
because of the deception that men
do we have such a guard up of what guys
we do go around but women go after the
bad guys and then complain
yeah
so you've got that
my thing is right so with this hypergamy
stuff is that
these women a lot of these women will
get with the key players these are the
guys that you know
when you dance there's certain guys that
just smash everyone in it they take
advantage of the new girls they tap
everyone so those girls they go with
that guy
and then now they've learned their
lessons they've dated mr toxic he did
this that this that he's telling me i'm
like uh-huh uh-huh uh-huh
and then they're like oh you know i want
to take it but it's slow with you
listen listen i was you know i was young
then i just you know you need to really
and i understand it because you know i
dismiss those women but
do you understand it though really i do
i do understand
because for a man
the advantage we have that's never
spoken of we have the advantage of
experience
like yeah we get screwed over and it's a
hustle but
i get i have infinite a lot of time to
figure it out in it women don't really
have that much time in it so for me past
a certain age past 27 when i've seen
enough i'm like oh snap i really get
like
um
for me every year there is a new cohort
of
young women who think they're grown
coming in and it's easy
it's it's extremely yo
no it's not even they all think they're
like you know i'm i'm 21 i'm graduate
from uni i know it bro listen there's
four of us here that specialize in these
women exactly like you i know where to
take you i know what to say i know what
you think of yourself
and it happens so that's the advantages
we have in it that every man is like
born like an rpg character in it we all
start on level one everyone even the
coolest guy leonardo dicaprio do you
mean as in um
because women after a certain age are
haven't got that you're born with it's
harder value women are born with value
so i have to earn my value yeah so i'm
invaluable say that again that's what
that's what no i'm saying the more you
sleep with men the less value will you
become oh i thought you know okay i'm
not saying that i know i'm saying
i mean
the older you get the less valuable if
you're over the guy was it who was it
kevin smith 35 you're undateable it
doesn't mean you're it doesn't mean
you're definitely not undetermined no
it's a low value
but it doesn't mean you're undateable it
means that you're less valuable than you
were when you were like 10 15 years ago
oh hunter you can't compete for example
you can't compete for the same guy but
i'm saying men it's the opposite the
older
people one in 15 years ago you're not no
i'm the same kind type of guy you're
competing for the same 20 percent of guy
even though you think it's a new guy
guys guys
because because okay i'm 25 right i
could date a guy up to 45 i'd be fine
with it and so like even even now we're
competing for the same guy
and that's so that's what he's saying
yeah so you've got the advantage you're
25 i get it and
just to clarify i wasn't saying that
like you know women are less valuable
with age it's just that obviously it
becomes a bit harder for women because
of age in the dating market because
obviously there are certain trends right
men tend to prefer younger women there
are certain elements of being younger
that are advantageous in dating like
vitality and having a certain mindset
that men can find refreshing at times it
gets harder for women i think we all
understand that right but for men
you know what the older you get the
better you learn to engage with women
you're better you know you don't say the
goofy stuff you used to say when you're
like 20. no the younger women are more
susceptible to your to your [ __ ] i
was going to say i think as you get
older you you tend to not really you
can't do the [ __ ] you can and you
can see it coming like straight right
but but this is where you go back to
it's the same same prize lower value
higher price yeah and that's that's the
biggest complaint i hear from men with
older women i'll tell you a story
actually this happened to me a few weeks
ago um there's two but i'll tell you
this one first so there was this girl i
met in a club she was great she was in a
similar scene as me
and she looked very good this night i'm
very direct with my interest i was like
damn yeah you looking good whatever
talking all that crap
um
we we're having a chat on the side and
she's you know acting all coy and she's
like i don't i don't date in this scene
i was like all right all right so uh
like so you want me you know your kind
of dinner date kind of girl cool cool
i found out that girl's been with almost
all of my boys
right so so for me for me she you know
she kind of you didn't continue you
didn't take oh no i didn't i did
instagram i got a number i never spoke
to her again and now she looks at me
like i'm some kind of alien every time
she sees me it's like
but that's that's the kind of story of
how it works sometimes does it make you
improve
absolutely because you knew that you was
at disadvantage when she told you that
right
yes i knew that there was something i
didn't understand and then when when my
boys told me like yeah like she's she's
been with their bear these man i said oh
okay i get it you just believed what
your friend said why would they lie why
wouldn't they lie
do you not think it's the same the other
way around though yeah so like if if i
meet a guy and i know that he's slept
with everyone in this community all of
my friends like do you really think i'm
still going to be yeah
most women are still attracted to him i
mean look at drake women are stealing
his condoms that's because he's famous
and people have this ludicrous kind of
imagery of celebrities that's true
that's true but in in general women pick
men that other women want
because it's a sign it's a sign of
pre-selection and the reason and i can
give you an example women say men are
trash all the time and they lie and they
cheat well who are they lying and
cheating i think that comes down to
like going back to the age thing as well
though because maybe when you're younger
you think about that but when you get
past a certain point you're kind of
looking for more stability
and somebody you can trust yeah i think
that really yeah because but that's
that's what happens though women below
the age of like 27 tend to date the bad
boys but and then and then they get ran
through by the bad boys and then ask for
a nice guy to pick up the pieces yeah
like why why should i have to deal with
your your issues after you've just
you had the chance when you was 21 the
chance when you was 22 23 twitter now i
want to go club i want to do this i want
to
please babes i want to wire for you no
no no i ain't got time for you
do you know on the count of three
everyone shout out their body count five
but do you get my point um
do you get my point if it's
no you're not ashamed of it because it's
five yeah if it was 55 you'd stay quiet
yeah
no you would stay quiet yes
if i was 55 it wouldn't have it wouldn't
necessarily me staying quiet because we
know what the um
what it's like like it's not it's not a
bad thing necessarily for me to be
sleeping around can i just say something
that i am
myself obviously i've had long-term
relationships so i'm fine but
what i will say is for the younger
generation
it's very difficult to have a low body
count now because and it's it's because
of older women not even
you lie to the younger women
let me just say something you've got
time
like you're saying dating and we're
saying connections and we're giving out
all this there's so many people that
social media has ruined dating it's like
there's so much variety there's so much
what you should be expecting what you
shouldn't be expecting so
it's so fickle dating is so fickle now
how how are young girls expected to keep
their body count down
when but
there's there's no relationships now
like it's not like back in the day where
you had a long-term life relationship
mostly our age were the last of the
long-term relationships i'm not gonna
lie well men men have definitely dropped
their standards for what they used to
accept a girl used to be a host she
slept with more than two people now a
guy prays for five
i don't know
i do listen and i've seen i've seen guys
i've seen a lot of hosts got wifed a lot
that's true
but they're also the first divorced
because i always say a woman sleeping
around it hurts herself more than anyone
else because it impacts her ability to
pair bond
so women have a hard time staying when
they've slept with too many people
statistically because yeah because women
that have slept with more than five men
yeah their their chance of a happy
marriage drops from about one eighty
percent after ten years they're going to
be in a happy marriage to 30
after five partners after 10 years so i
can't sleep with any more guys or else
i'm going to drop in a present
that is it's not nice
so i need to find my husband right now
no more sex
but that's what i'm saying is like
there's reasons behind it
do you think do you think that's going
to work
no more sex yeah dude like that's what i
mean when i say you making him wait and
you're making him wait
the guy just had it like that it's like
now i'm i'm on my i'm on my i'm just
going to have to go back to someone i've
had sex with yeah that's what i said
that's why i asked you you should have
married your partner
oh come on man no no that's not i know
you explained it to me but that's why at
first i said you should have married
your partner if you married your partner
in year one you would have divorced when
your problems happen but you would have
been married
but what's that that's just no i mean i
don't listen i grew up here i grew up
let me let me give you this i don't know
if it's my cousin's fault i blame her um
i was a protestant in scotland as
protestant catholics my cousin was a
catholic as a protestant she got to make
a communion and i didn't
she religiously i stayed at her house
and most days when my mom was working
she used to dress me in a trouser suit
and she dressed up in her communion
dress and made us play weddings like in
the living in front of everyone and it
really daunted me that she always made
me be the guy like it hurt me a lot so i
just was like i hate weddings
i don't know if it's instilled i haven't
ever had the wish to be married i don't
dream of the white dress i don't at the
commitment that is for the government to
say you're married like i dream of real
love like that's all i've ever done but
marriage marriage is a
and it's a business
you're right and when i left i realized
that i failed in that business
transaction mm-hmm yeah because he held
most of the mon the money
but i think that's like the what we have
confused as women is we're in it for
love but it's not about love it's about
what works long term and building family
and i hear you and i hear you and i hear
what you're saying and for my
my beautiful daughters i did stay a lot
lot lot longer than i should have a lot
longer but when they got to a certain
age
and maturity and i realized that this
was actually affecting them because i
didn't want what i realized is i thought
was acceptable because i'd seen my
parents do similar things so i thought
that was acceptable i'd never seen i've
nev i've never seen a one nurturing
relationship i'm not sure you don't have
to say what wasn't acceptable
anything
it's not acceptable so i didn't want my
daughters to then i i think sometimes we
rerun our parents relationship no no i
said no because you're not allowed to
say that word oh oh you're not okay yeah
so i just felt like i'd
see i just felt like i thought it was
acceptable because i grew up seeing it
so therefore i didn't want them to think
that was acceptable or that was how
relationships were supposed to be so i
decided not to do it and when you said
to me 18 years you should have stayed no
way
i believe in if if it's unhappy it
affects your kids worse
in the case of abuse i would agree with
you yeah in abuse but i think that's
more of the exception rather than the
rule
because women leave seventy to eighty
percent of the time ninety percent if
we're college educated
and one of the number one predictors of
if you're going to get a divorce is if
you out earn your husband
do you think that's because of the women
or because of the men i think it's
because women are hypergamous and it's
hard for a woman to be attracted to a
guy she makes more than
because in my personal circumstances the
issue i've always had is a man not being
secure enough to accept the fact that
i've done better than that absolutely i
think i think the problem is you've done
better but yeah that's that's the
problem is like women and it kind of
shows in the way you talk respectfully
like it sounds like you like yeah it
sounds like you're acting like you're
better than yeah that's not what i mean
yeah but i'm saying a lot of like women
unintentionally act like they're better
than the guy and then it makes him
insecure but so the way you look is i
like
for me personally obviously everyone's
different but for me personally when i'm
looking for a guy
i care about
if what they're doing they have passion
for what they're doing they have drive
for what they're doing regardless of how
they are financially because when you're
with somebody you're a couple right
you're a team in that so it doesn't
matter who the higher earner is it
matters if they can provide you with
that emotional support and that
stability and i think that sounds nice
but that's just not women what women
pick and i think when we say things like
that it's dishonest but it's because
it's not it's it is what happens no
because women when you survey women
where they're not in front of them on
camera with mics in their faces
they say they want a guy that makes at
least 30 more than that they say this
this is from the horse's mouth okay as
yeah of course i've never dated a guy
that's that's kind of uh more than i
have well i mean you also aren't married
though so you didn't stay with one
but they left me
but uh i think
it even kind of aligns with my
experience so nigerian background the
last generation of nigerians were very
like you know pioneers they did very
very well goldman sachs and all the
women especially the women who did
really well
are like
found it extremely hard to settle down
because of that reason they all said
oh i need i need someone who's like
better than me he's like earns more than
me and these women were like top lawyers
like they were like killing it and there
were all these guys they had all the
options they had the looks they had all
the physical assets that men liked and
they struggled for decades in some cases
and i think some of them still aren't
married now because and you know
nigerians are very vocal so you're going
to family you know reunions and weddings
and they weren't they weren't shy of
saying yeah like if if you don't and if
you can't compete with me earnings wise
i've got twin sister and you know
even then you kind of hear those kind of
sentiments
um or this idea that like if you settle
for someone who you know it doesn't end
as much reason as six successful as you
are that you're like settling and this
is this could be like a six foot four
muscle-bound uni educated women always i
mean why do we know the phrase we know
this phrase when i say oh i want a man
on my level women say that all the time
you don't hear men saying oh i want a
woman on my level what do you think
that's because i think it's because
women are hypergamous and men aren't
women want a guy that they they can look
up to i don't think it's a bad thing
that's okay i think it's okay i actually
agree with that phrase i want a guy on
my level but that doesn't come down to a
monetary value
alone
money muscle's framing game
really 666 do you not think that sounds
very kind of shallow in terms of the way
you look at things like i i think it
depends on what what you need as a
person because your circumstances your
upbringing your life is gonna determine
what you need from someone else you're
right there's individual differences but
when you survey women and ask them like
from the horse's mouth at large what
they want in them and a guy it's money
muscles frame game
what do you mean by frame sorry frame is
like masculinity basically muscles and i
will say when you said it's also what
you need personally from a woman i was
going to point on to that uh i've you
know we've all been there where like you
meet someone at a time where they need a
certain kind of guy maybe she's been
dumped by some you know some player and
she needs a nice guy for a bit but after
those needs have been met
it's money frames and games baby i
wasn't gonna know that point i was gonna
say why is it about what you need like i
don't think a man goes into a
relationship saying
what can what do i need from a woman
it's like no like what can i provide for
her what can our family do together
where could like um i promise you i'm
not like what if a man says he wants
something from you you would think he's
a weirdo he'd be like right he's like
it's it's like why does he want
something from me like no you tell your
bridge and if you if
say for example
you got a friend where the guy is she's
constantly paying for or she's
constantly doing um the things that you
would typically consider a man doing
yeah you would tell her you'd be like
later why are you with that guy like
he's trying to take advantage of you
yeah
you see there we go i've heard i've
heard that i've heard that being said
right so that's what i'm talking about
when i say in terms of what you need
from that i think with i don't know if
it's with age
but
money
genuinely doesn't come into it for me
don't get me wrong don't get me wrong
i'm not gonna lie i i will not i will
sit here and i'll be honest
if i met two guys in the if i met two
guys exact same guy and one said yeah
exact same guy and one said
do you want to go out on monday
i'm going to pick you up
and the other one said do you want to go
out on monday
yeah we'll check train times and i'll
meet you there
i'm not going to lie
i probably will go for the one that's
going to pick me up right yeah what if i
told you the train guy has 35 million in
his bank account and the reason why wait
wait wait and the reason why he's not
taking car and pick dropping you because
it's in the garage would you still go
with the guy that's picking you up in
the car
yeah no i don't know that i'm confused
because now you've confused me
you can you confuse everyone you don't
know what you want
a man just needs to be able to look
after himself yeah i just feel like
you've kind of got your stuff together
but the point is if there's guy a and
guy b and one has money and one what
does it yeah you're telling me you
wouldn't pick the guy with money it's
exactly exactly the same yeah yeah you
probably would yeah yeah i mean if
there's not really a good comparison if
they're exactly the same but just one
has money
but the point is that plays into it
where men don't care
men don't care all about a woman's money
like and a lot of times girls will come
out and they'll say oh i have my own bag
and like think that's attractive to a
guy but it's only attractive to broke
men yeah of course okay
if you have the exact same comparison
though and you say to a guy okay has
women a and women b who are exactly the
same and the only thing how would you
pick between the two then yeah
it would be money
what would it be but for us you're
assuming
can you answer this question
okay so
just rephrase the question so girl a
girl b one has money one doesn't one
makes 500k a year one makes forty five
but they're exactly the same that's
exactly the same yeah
money won't i don't care about money and
the reason why i won't care about money
is purely because i'm gonna judge them
like let's say girl a they're exactly
the same but
girl is like hella disrespectful she
doesn't understand what i as a man need
i think you'll be exactly the same
understands what a man needs
is submissive in certain ways that shows
me respect and loyalty which is what i
value
i'm picking gilbee
so so then
being exactly the same it does money
doesn't matter can i actually
i'd probably flip a coin
you said as a minute ago you said they
don't understand what i need now when i
said
looking at what you'd look at what you
need from a man you picked up on that
and said why does it matter what the
woman needs and assumed it was a
monetary value thing where i was talking
about emotionally and mentally but when
you've said that
nobody said anything that's not what i'm
talking about he's talking about in
terms the man's needs in terms of a
man's needs i could fulfill my own needs
when you're coming into relationship
you'll probably come with university
debt you're probably coming with
problems from your ex relationship
you're probably coming with
like past issues about emotional needs
you're haunting a lot of everyone for
women
okay
so wait guys guys one more time so
here's the difference
emotional needs you will seek
a man to help you with that whereas i as
a man
if i've got emotional needs i will not
come to you with those emotional needs
and the reason being is that you as a
woman will not understand the struggle
as a man that i go through on a daily
basis so it's very difficult for you to
comprehend and give me advice
on how to deal with my emotional
problems i as a man will probably be
best off
going to seek advice from other males
that i could call friends maybe
counselors in that kind of realm
in order to get advice on how to go
about my emotional problems yeah
you don't think women could do the same
thing but i think women
pulses it best women are chemically
different on a day-to-day basis and so
the idea that i could say all right guys
i'm going through these problems you may
see it from a woman's perspective and
you'll go oh well you can do this this
and this
as a man if i take that advice i do
those things i will find the results
are not
suitable or
what i'm looking for because you as a
woman women tend to be more money
colored in today's society
men if you do something you will know by
it
you society will tell you that
this can't run and you can't do that
women get away with everything
shout out to people
anytime anytime a guy has a standard
there's a shame for it but you started
off this conversation by saying don't
you think women have too high standards
they do but i just that's why
that's why 50 of women are single and
childless but that contradicts exactly
what you how does it contradict exactly
what i said because you just said if men
have a standard they're kind of ashamed
for it yeah i'll give you an example
what what happened with the slut-shaming
slut-shaming fatphobic where's the
equivalent of that for men they don't
exist
if anything if i meet anyone and they
ever say anything to me and i need a
statistic and it's about women and men
i'm fine and proud
[Laughter]
on everything
okay literally you're allowed to have
standards as a woman what we're talking
about is too high of a standard where it
only encompasses 20 of men that standard
if you broaden your standard to include
like let's say 50 you would have a
higher chance of being in a relationship
correct because you have more people so
that's what we're talking about the
reason why a lot of you are single is
because your standards are too high
men's standards are not the same like
the same the same with the two girls
with the money it doesn't matter for me
what she has the more likely i'll take
the one with less because the one with
more is going to come with complications
she's going to be like i'm the boss of
this stuff i have the most money no no
you can't tell me nothing and dinner
i'm like yo
i don't need the stress i find it really
interesting that you say that because
speaking to all of the women that i know
who are currently single the issues that
we always have are you go on dates you
put yourself into somebody you invest
your time and they all seem to have
commitment issues so that's why because
you're dating 20 percent
yeah
i promise you the bottom percent of guys
they where are they they have no
commitment issues none of them
they're less attractive
the man has commitment issues
in in my experience but that's what i'm
saying to you because he's not going to
tell you listen darling this is your
problem this is a b problem this is c
problem this is the problem i'm just
gonna cut cut or i'm gonna stay there
and not take you seriously
if if he's not committing to you it's
because it's something you're not doing
or you're not fulfilling for him in
terms of what he wants purely the
woman's fault if a man's not committed
if you're not if a girl is asking for
let's say she her asking price is this
much and she says this is this is the
product this is what i'm selling can
someone buy it and nobody buys
something's wrong with the product
good to know
all the prices the price or the price
yeah or the price or the buyer this is
just so you're basically saying there's
there's no issue with
so
with the fact that it's so easily
accessible to move on to the next person
with having social media with having
dating apps now that that hasn't caused
an issue in terms of individuals now
committing
what does social media have to do with
the conversation so i find that social
media has a major thing to do with the
conversation in terms of dating because
expectations are set so high
i think it's i think what people expect
i think it raises women's expectations
more than i think raises men's i think
it raises
because women's our dm's are flooded
they are that's true yeah and so it
gasses women's up and women up and think
they're hotter than they are because
they can get you can be an average chick
and an nba player slide into your dms it
kills your confidence it's like as a
dude
don't get me wrong i i don't think it's
great either way but i do think there's
an issue in terms of it it sets
expectations to be higher and then when
you have so much access
to speaking to you know hundreds of
women on a daily basis men also become
more picky
it's a small
it's a small percentage of men that are
picky because again
yeah yes
and that's what i'm saying you're right
it is harder to get the small percentage
of guys to commit
because if you find this guy attractive
a lot of other women probably do too why
would he commit when he can just bang a
bunch of chicks let's put all the 20
on an island somewhere and we'll all
live happily ever you would go to the
island
don't tell me where the island is
what is the exact time and location
i'm a good swimmer
you want to go to the eye and only that
if you take away the 20 of the guys and
put them on the island then there'll be
a new 20 of guys that you are now
interested in exactly let everyone get a
chance man so you you always want the
top you can't settle settle
settle for what you like it's like lower
your ex lower your expectations i don't
think that's that's i don't think that's
a hot take but
what go ahead i don't think it's the hot
take to so so i guess my opinion on this
is a bit more nuanced than that yes
everyone has you know expectations that
can vary and sometimes they can be a bit
ridiculous
so but i don't think that's a bad thing
i actually actually enjoy the house on i
don't think it's a hot take to tell
women
that hey you should you should settle
for less you should settle for the
average xyz i think it's your job as a
man to be
that that top person you're either a
baiter or you're a successful man
inside inside of this in the dating game
because only a man that's winning will
say that
[Music]
i will tell you i'm not necessarily
winning i could be doing better but
you know and i i think i'm far from a
beta i just that's just my my nature are
you virgin
no see so you're winning then
because you're you're in the higher
percent you're in a smaller percentage
of men that's actually being sexually i
do quite well there you go
it doesn't it doesn't favor you to
change it maybe like it doesn't fit i'm
very picky though but i think it's it's
more about like the attitude though i
think it's more like because when you
when i say i do quite well that but i
probably go out more than you i probably
put more time and energy into
understanding the game than you i've
probably had more experiences that have
affected my dating experience you know
these people so people act like you know
it just happens it takes work and i'm
gonna keep working on it you're right
there is a gr there is a group of men
that like are addicted to corn right
they just play video games they're not
working on themselves and they have bad
results and you don't really feel bad
for them for having bad results but on
the other hand you have women that are
super overweight asking for a guy that
makes six figures
and like you don't see that type of male
delusion wow well you actually do see
some of that because i know i know a lot
of gamer boys with very poor social
skills that think they're entitled to
you know top shelf women like but being
real do you really feel like it's at the
same rate i mean it's processed
differently that guy gets shut down it's
embarrassing yeah that's that's what i'm
saying like like men are faced with
reality quick yeah women aren't because
we lie to each other that guy's not
happy yeah and then we and then we have
movements like you know slut-shaming
right fat phobic we have all these
movements to like cushion us yeah and
don't get it twisted i have my
frustrations with women as well like i
think in a casual dating game there is
definitely
um
expectations are quite high and i think
personally a lot of women don't
understand how to have a healthy casual
relationship i think people mix it up
with very sentimental sentimentality and
that's why they get played by the same
guys because these guys know you want a
connection you're saying you're a big
girl but you know when they mess with me
they're like oh why aren't you texting
me at night because we're a casual
relationship i'm not gonna kiss you good
night you can have a healthy
casual relationship that's that's my
view yeah and i've yeah i don't know
absolutely
definitely it just takes maturity you
just have to be transparent be
transparent be mature um yeah you love
playing with fire i don't know
i don't care
maybe i'm fine i don't think women are
biologically predispositioned for it
like statistically they're not they're
not and and i think as a guy you're like
yeah you can have a healthy casual
relationship because that's a man's
point of view and some and some girls
can do it but like in my experience
typically like they've just had a bunch
of sex to the point they don't care
anymore
in my experience every time we orgasm we
fall in love with this guy so the casual
relationship
not not every time i'm saying early on
so so girls typically bond more with the
first couple of guys they slept with
yeah okay and and so and they tend to do
that through orgasm yeah
orgasms here's the problem in my
experience though that the women who
tend to be able to be able to do this
are they tend to be older they tend to
be like over 27. yeah they don't
necessarily have a higher body count but
they're normally very educated they have
that they're independent they have their
own lives so my my ideal woman is
actually what a lot of people would say
is the women woman that'll give them the
most stress because these guys say well
this woman thinks she won the show yeah
you can run the show i'll see you once
every two weeks
what am i fussing about or you know
women who are still in love with some
other dude cool you can see him in the
two weeks i'm not seeing you you know
and and if you think like that that's
called frame though because i have
nothing to prove and when we want to
escalate the relationship then there are
a lot of ways that you can build
closeness but i'm just i'm just someone
where i know what what when what i'm
doing is building a more intimate
relationship than our relationship is
actually at so you're the side guy
no i'm the main guy actually no in terms
of like if she's got a partner and you
see you see her be in between the
relationships you're like the side guy
no she this is not married women this is
just women who are around maybe they may
be seeing multiple guys i don't ask
because i don't care
so you're winning in the game then
casual relationship in the casual game
but it's a mindset though that's the
thing i'm asking if
i'm saying are you winning yes or no i
do all right so wouldn't it wouldn't it
be like um bad for you if the game was
to change and women to stop having
casual sex with you counterproductive
wouldn't it be counterproductive if
women was to stop having casual sex yes
i guess so right so you're not right so
you're not you're not advised to give um
advice the right advice
because because you telling girls to
sleep around benefit to you exactly yeah
but it can also benefit them as well
what is
what is the most conducive to building
families
a stable emotional relationship yeah
yeah and so like that's why you see 50
of women over 30 being single and
childless and then you have the least
happy group of women or 45 that make
over fifty thousand dollars per year
that's the least happy group of women so
casual relationships leave women unhappy
in the long term if they don't have a
family yeah but that also depends on the
mentality of the people around them the
men at the time so
a woman you can consider quite pious now
you could go back 10 years and she's now
someone who's
acting completely wilding out oh yeah
part of it is like the the birth the
society you're in birth control change
dating forever yeah like that in a way
you can't go back absolutely but yeah i
i personally i don't think casual sex is
is the worst thing but it has to be
approached with care it's not something
you do carelessly this idea that yeah
just sleep around check whoever you want
whatever is is the reason that a lot of
these girls are out here getting played
and crossing two things casual and
intimate and they don't even know but i
know in it okay i'm gonna read super
chats for a hot second um
okay
so guys
as you know who wants to know what ish
looks like everyone in the chat put a
one in the chat if you want to know what
ish looks like yes people let's go so
guys send donations so we can get a
camera next month so we're trying to
save up for the end of next month to get
ish a camera ish good looking guy i know
you guys want to know what he looks like
drum roll please we trying yeah yeah
okay so beef 20 super chat thank you we
do not have beef because you are
subscribed um trevor elaine dude got
shot in the armpit um
um lazarius um it isn't it isn't even
settling it's going for a man who's
actually checking for you who can match
you you attract what you are not what
you want cheesy may women believe that
men's experience on social media is the
same as theirs they don't live in
reality and that's and they're not
required to ask the
why the white lady in black if she dates
black men
20 of men are highlighted in women's
minds or where the other 80 are almost
invisible you only see them when you
need something you want or desire army d
the male version of hypergamy is a nice
body and a great attitude and that
indian woman is fine and mary d another
10 super chat jin
oh god guys these names jin
ricky or msela my mother had three boys
she explained many times that women
earning more will bring it up in
marriages and hold it over the man's
head
find sebastian shaw the voice in the
corner please stop you will keep
inflating other countries with the uk
and you have an issue with classism big
link to black people's fool jeezy may
uh gz may a man doesn't care about how
much money a woman makes but a woman
will talk down to men they don't look up
to find sebastian shaw women need to
stop moaning uv now got the power of
your body and there's no more blaming us
for potentially being a piece of crap
you can choose please choose wisely
gzmay women want men who are experienced
and desirable if a guy told a girl he
was a virgin she wouldn't be interested
in sex with him for lack of experience
da prequel
um advice for single poppies stephone
pierre stephen pierre jerome society
lets us women use the excuse i was young
and stupid as a get out of jail free
card guys from the time they were born
are held accountable as grown men um
w-r-y-d-d-a no after 35 you were
undateable because by that time you have
too much life experience and you're
stuck in your ways and you're on
moldable
refund md1 hey pearl wanted to send you
a tick tock milk at the movement husband
requirement 300 pounds asking for yearly
honeymoons and she does no housework
dear
when we want a life partner with a low
mileage we find the queen of hearts when
we want a good time regardless of
mileage we get with the queen of clubs
and diamonds and spades sims dogs and
feminists ruin marriage partners
dc081 ladies you need to shape up
because robot women with artificial
wombs eternal youth and beauty and
customizable looks aren't very far off
apollo dart day there's a big difference
between what a man likes to see and what
he wants to have for life black panth
panther the only fan's economy is built
off the decline in male mental health
and there are women selling thousands of
dollars of their used bath water to
these kinds of men dub men question for
the women would you be okay if the guy
slept with someone else until you were
ready to sleep with him that's actually
a decent question um the uk economist
asked your guests would they prefer
their daughter waiting for marriage or
wasting their time sleeping with random
men ice hollow field if she sleeps
around
and then makes me wait that's like me
spoiling all my other girls and deciding
to be humble and take her to mcdonald's
to see if she's a gold digger
dumb man it's easy for women to make a
guy weight because there's no cost to
her meanwhile the guy is spending money
on dates with no return on investment
brennan ocean women let alpha males and
make better males wait mr minister
respect samuels for to for the buy dog
and die alone phrase steven pierre
jerome preach pearl good guys are often
placeholders for the guys they really
want and good guys are starting to wake
up dub men five dollar super chat ed ed
sen polo why girl
why girls think men wants to live
wait why girls think men want to live
them it does not cross me to leave my
wife so they don't all think like that
let me refresh and see if there's any
more
also guys all the super chats are going
towards updates in the studio and sign
up for our memberships i think we're
about to turn on our members only chat
so if you want to be a part of the
members only chat you got to sign up for
memberships okay digital sparks beta
white hat is sweating like he's being
interrogated by the ci cia guys it's
pretty hot in here
it's crazy huh it's it's hot we don't
have ac in the uk i don't know why
someone gave him a glass of ice water
and put a fan on him richard alvirez
high value men are valuable because they
provide security stability and status a
high value man should be a regular guy
with a nine to five stable job good
value and that works out this is what
changed to this change to what we
consider a high value man flask are
women don't care about men's issues
because they don't have to until they
hit the wall and they're rescued from
father time for real from sapien high
alley free my dude ish get that man a
camera
elijah abdulman my monthly contribution
one day-ish one day
um larson the guy in the white white cap
tries to go against the majority it
doesn't matter what the topic is um and
then that's it hey
um jess i don't know if you can open the
door back there but maybe we can it'll
actually make it a little cooler in here
because i'm sweating too
okay um so we have some new panelists hi
guys i know you guys introduced in the
beginning
um so my question and this is kind of
going back to what we were asking
earlier
when
so 50 of women over 30 are single in
child
give the lowest birth rate ever
practically in human history
when should women settle and when are
their standards too high
i think their standards are too high
when it becomes
unattainable okay
and um
illogical um as far as when they should
settle
i can't answer that but with regards to
standards being too high i feel like if
something's unattainable then your
standards are too high just by default
okay what do you guys think
i don't necessarily think our standards
are too high i think like so
you should be typically
being of a virgin as a woman
before you actually
like before you actually have sex with a
man be thinking about putting a ring on
it
and i would always say that right
say that
sex before marriage bro like oh you're
saying sex before marriage is important
no i'm saying mari
you shouldn't be having sex before i got
you i'm i'm
going to say you're going to start from
now on no no no no i'm saying the reason
why girls should practice
marriage before sex is because the other
way around disadvantages them mm-hmm it
doesn't disadvantage me i i i'm
completely in my zone when you don't
want arcs for commitment yeah i don't i
don't need it like it's not
you know i mean it's not i don't have to
spend money on you i don't have to be
thinking about you i don't have to do
like do you know what i mean so it's
worse for you if we don't have a
commitment so women should not sleep
with men before they are married yes but
the bible said that the quran
if they're virgins but the problem is
you have women that you know get ran
through
and then ask the guy to wait and i'm not
sure that's the best strategy but you
said as well um our connections are
built through sex and sex is a very
important part yes
what
what happens for the divorce money
because what if the thing is [ __ ] i've
waited
you've got a big o ring
your sex is dead okay the pastor would
you how would you know
how would you know it's bad sex if
you've never had sex with anyone else
unless like like those you only know for
one of two reasons that you're comparing
him to another guy or your friends are
telling you stuff he's not yeah my
friend is probably saying your mints and
maybe some things are meant to happen at
this at a point in sex but then you can
grow with someone when it comes to sex
isn't it like so
you can have sex with someone for the
first time and it's not that good but
then once you stay it's called practice
ladies you're gonna miss a lot of good
sex if you do that no no no because you
know what it is like i think feminism
got confused yeah they're like oh men
were sitting down in a dark corner or
cuddling together thinking how can we
screw over women instead of thinking it
as men actually love their women and
think how can we best protect our women
and our daughters the best way is for
her to be married my daughter to be
married with a man that i've
vetted i've i've made sure he's all
right
yes it's hypergamous but i vetted him
even like you know i mean we're we're
marrying a family to another family of
two um
would you call it
two decent families
we're not just marrying the person we're
marrying the family as well so you're
marrying so now when you're 89 and
you've got all your kids and your
auntie's around you're not lonely you
don't have the cat around you you know
i'm trying to say you you enjoy your
life and fulfill your life because
that's what the main purpose of life
isn't it to reproduce the happiest life
for a woman is simply that she doesn't
run through loads of men she gets
married
she has a loads of kids
she gets to have grandkids and then
later on she gets spoiled by standing in
her living room and she's got
20 30 people that have all just come
from her and at the end of the day
it's not that well ultimately
women
they can't have they can't have been
[ __ ] down by so many different men and
then expect to have a man take them
seriously in a long-term relationship
it's okay making it's okay making the
man wait ever so slightly but that's if
he knows you don't have a history of
being run through by loads of different
men i think that alone is going to give
men the security to say right look i'm
now willing to wait a little bit because
i know that this woman's heart is in it
for the right reason and now i know that
i can wife her and we can do it for the
right reason we can actually have kids
and we can have a long-lasting
relationship personally i do agree with
you all that actually the the
government's involvement to me is
[ __ ] as well i hate it but
the sentiment of it
is far more biologically
beneficial to you
but men men will opt in as long as you
don't have that background because you
don't have that history and as long as
loyalty is there first and foremost and
that you would treat man so you would
treat your men
as men don't get wrong they have to be
men in the first place and by men i mean
actual masculine men
they have to have the right frame they
have to have the finances in order but
as long as they can see that you have
the right history you have the right
motive and then the loyalty is there
altogether
i think we could all agree in here that
relationship is now going to last and
it's going to be fruitful forever what's
more what's more important a low body
count or loyalty
what's more important
i don't think i need to pick either one
they tend to be the same i'm going to
say they kind of they go hand in hand
because if a girl has a higher body
count it's more baggage it's more excess
he has to deal with it's more like i
hate this term but like alpha widows
yeah i've never heard that yeah it's
basically like the x that the girl can't
get over but there's more of them
the more people she slept with i do
agree with certain points that you said
about game i do agree with body count
and i do
i was raised on
women shouldn't get round through and i
do agree with that and i'll preach that
to my daughters
but i don't what i don't agree with is
the perfect
family the scenario the the greatest
thing for a woman is when she's standing
in her living room with 30 people
celebrating her
yeah for some people yeah for some
people that is that is their life goal
i don't
think my i've got a few people in my
family that can't have kids
so that's the exception that's the
exception and that's an exception so is
to say
is to say she can't have kids her life
is any less fulfilled
than
my other auntie that has got that maybe
maybe but she's living her best life on
in foreign like is she she's had she's
she's had to adjust to ultimate you've
got women yeah i hear you so we can
adjust and i don't think her life is any
less fulfilled no it's not it's not
going to be in it no it's not going to
be any less fulfilled i mean technically
it will be
saying she has been through probably
periods of her life but she's one of the
kids
but but again i mean that is the
exception to the rule and it doesn't
mean she can't be happy but she's not
going to be as happy now that's just the
sad truth of it right but if
if you're a woman i mean to go back to
your previous point
what would a woman want more than to
later on be out to say that they're a
grandmother great grandmother with loads
of loads of kids load of people that
have come from there what will i know
you said that that's not every woman's
goal what goal would you say a woman
would value more than that long term
that society hasn't told us she should
have yeah i'm
like i want i want to cut the 30
grandkids 30 great grandkids down to
like eight nine because the cost of
living out here is crazy yeah that's a
little christmas present
but the point is the point is if a woman
doesn't prioritize a family she ends up
unhappy in the long term in general i
thought
like
because this is when you survey women
because it's it's all fun and games when
you're still hot right and you still
look good right and you still get
attention from men but at some point
that goes away like no guys are lining
up to date 50 year olds yeah and you're
going to live to be 90 go ahead yeah
sorry we have that window so that's why
we want that commitment fertility window
yeah yeah so we need to
we need to
optimize in that and try and
find that commitment
when we're in that window so then so
women want women are nurturing they want
to have kids naturally
not all natural naturally you do
but i believe the only reason why some
women will say they don't and i i
personally believe i'm
yet to be convinced otherwise is because
modern day social conditioning society
has convinced you that's not your
ultimate goal but if you actually
walk into a dark room with nobody in
there by yourself completely quite and
ask yourself what do you want what does
your biology want i think you know the
answer when you ask girls that are 18
and they're graduating high school they
all want to be married with kids that's
the first thing yeah but who sold them
that dream
as well it's definitely not society you
have feminism pushing you can get your
own bag female empowerment like i've
been told from the youngest age that i
can do whatever i want society's telling
you that you should have this big career
yeah and make it on your own and
[ __ ] that's
not what you're doing you're just gonna
if you're gonna be
like a
a high up lawyer with loads of money you
may have loads of money but you'll be
lonely because you won't have
your children you get a couple of more
holidays a year out of your money so
[ __ ] what at the end of the day what
does it matter to you if you've not got
a family that's ultimately what you want
to have children
i mean that's the gift that we have yeah
that's not how to procreate like you're
breeding machines
that's literally what you're
biologically designing
i know this but i want to ask you guys
something here
now the lgbt community yeah should be
allowed to
conduct themselves how they conduct
themselves
right so we
more than likely we're not going to get
any kids from that area yeah yeah now
the women that we're now telling
go to work go to career and stuff
don't have kids late now we're telling
those women not to have kids what do you
think happens to the human race when
people stop having kids
people become distinct when they come
inside that's what i'm talking about so
we need a man and a woman to have kids
right
right otherwise we need to continue the
human race and to sorry sorry to cut you
in but so it's kind but on that point
people have got to understand that what
we're fed to believe we want and what we
want on a dna level cellular level
are two different things and this brings
me back to the very point you all
touched on earlier with regards to what
men are looking for in women and what
women are looking for in men and this is
just for anybody watching at the end of
the day
the simple breakdown
i provide for people is if you're if
you're if you're a man
for any man in this room if i was to sit
here and break down
a woman so for example
i would say she's
she's very very caring she loves her
career yeah
right she's very very driven she's got
loads of friends around her that love
and respect that her family adores the
pieces highly educated
what is every single man in this room
thinking right now
in what sense
if i was to describe a woman and start
off and purely
lay out those
um
attributes or traits or her history
right what what for any guy in here or
any guy listening what question do you
have in mind what's the first question
you have what does she look like thank
you very much right it all comes down to
the aesthetics in the beginning right
now for women
it is slightly different in that
now if i was to say
he's
a great looking guy
chisel jaw
big dick
tall
why
what does he do for us thank you very
much
you've broke so the first thing you want
to know who is he what does he do what
is connections what's his status right
in society
i think deep down every single woman
asks those questions and if i was to say
along with those things
if i was to drop it on you now say that
he's a complete bum he's going nowhere
in life he still lives in his mom's
basement and he's got no drive to
accomplish anything in life nobody
around him respects him he's got no
friends and there's no girls trying to
hit him up what would you say now
get the [ __ ] away from me is what you
say
i always say
is designed for our survival yeah
exactly i don't want to date a bomb like
i i hope to god you guys don't want to
date bombs
so you're saying guys would like a girl
who's bummy yes
at least
a woman being a bum to us we don't
really look at women as bums for us it's
more to do with your loyalty yeah and
it's to do with your attitude in life
whether you're arrogant whether you've
got that
overly confident nature to us it's
repulsive but a woman having no money
and a woman not being well connected do
you think we give a [ __ ] because that's
not our ultimate goal
ultimately on a dna level and this is
what most men need to understand this is
what we act on it's primal so on a dna
level we are ultimately after
good breeding stock so you need to have
and this is this is a woman's display of
good breeding stock good genes is by
having a great physique a beautiful face
she's youthful she's young she's within
that peak fertility window
she does have a clock and sooner or
later that will run out and then she'll
she'll end up on the other side of that
where
men are now not looking at her for sex
they're not looking for biological
reasons maybe for
value as far as being a great nanny or
for example being great with kids being
valuable in different areas but we are
not looking at you and thinking
i am going to get good good kids with
good genes out of you once you're past
that window and that is even more so for
menopause
yeah because geriatric pregnancy starts
at 35. so your options start to run out
they don't recommend having a kid over
what like 37 38.
from the studies i've read is between
around 16 17 to around
early 30s is when they say it's a
woman's peak fertility yeah but and the
problem is you have rich people pushing
a luxury lifestyle on average people
like geriatric uh ivf which is something
like girls always say it's 25 000 who
has that lying around
and you have rich people that can do
that right like the kardashians they all
had kids later in life they're fine but
it's because they could afford to the
average girls can't do that and so you
have feminism pushing like chase the bag
chase the career get ran through and and
basically piss away your the most
valuable thing you have which is your
youth and your fertility not only that
pearl what what tends to happen is that
i feel like there's an agenda
in terms of there is a benefit to to
certain people that women are single
not in control of their finances
spending and they've got money so
they've got they've got
um a lot of money coming in
they're not tied down
but they're spending money somewhere so
yeah because seven women make 70 to 80
percent of consumer buying decisions
and so there is an agenda in keeping
women single right because you're not
going to buy no big birking bag when
you're in the room well women women
women make less money but spent own
two-thirds of the world's debt even
though we make 10 to fifteen thousand
dollars pounds less than men per year
and so we have less money and we spend
more
hundred percent i never thought that
yeah yeah we're impulsive yeah yeah but
it's really important we're chemically
different we can't
we can't help it we have self we're
adults but like like on some primal
level we're chemically different every
day
so
like
we're more like emotional beings yeah
yeah we're more likely to respond to to
make impulsive decisions that's what it
is
and your friends are not going to help
you because she wants to make those
decisions as well so it's like the only
person that's really there is the guy
that's just like the cheap guy that we
called it you know what i'm saying he's
controlling the final like no you can't
keep doing this babes like you know i
mean like we can't afford it we need
distant distant distances that came
through the lid no that's the letter
that's why we stay higher in it so i
have i have a question for the women
would you okay if you had a guy
i i don't i know it varies for every
girl so imagine a guy that has every
single thing that you want like perfect
guy
would you overlook cheating
from time to time
just a side check no i would you would
you'd overlook it i wouldn't you
wouldn't even if also your bills are
taken care of completely till you die i
wouldn't you wouldn't okay
i wouldn't um if i had kids they might
be different but if i didn't say too
yeah if i didn't have kids
um and i was still i felt like
if i was still like maybe my age now
um
yeah i wouldn't overlook it because a
trait that i look for is loyalty
and
for me i understand that the male nature
is to spread his seed you know go find
out what like what he wants
and
yeah so i i can understand that but i
also think that
them given into that nature of you know
like even if it didn't mean anything it
was just
like a one-night stand you know he was
just caught up in the moment
that to me would
be like you're you're a weak man you
can't hold like especially if we had
something really good going on
and we had a really good relationship
we've been together a really long time
and
and then you just [ __ ] up one night
like that to me is disrespectful to me
and then i wouldn't go back with you
because
now you would probably do that again
because i've accepted that that's how
you are now you you [ __ ] up from time to
time can i just ask have you been in
that position before
no i've never been to it done
that you know what you know of i was
just gonna say
so for you why did you say yes
i don't believe that men
can not cheat okay and when i say men i
mean most men
i think i think i think they're just
built to
i think
you're in the
because you're assuming that the woman
is
like somehow like deserving of just me
alone no no what makes you think she's
no that's not her words let her say what
she's saying she said she guys let her
talk she said cheat guys let her talk go
ahead go ahead
yeah i don't i don't i don't believe
that men
can just be with one person is that from
experience you've been like cheated on a
lot i've in fact i've been cheated on
but i've never found out until when i
was it was way way way away something
he's never affected me but
i kind of feel like
it's a scientific or genetic whatever
you want to what however you want to put
it i i feel like men they they think
with their penises and
i wouldn't i personally if i was with
someone for many many years and then i
found out that they cheated on me i
wouldn't throw away a whole
that you know that whole sort of
relationship for for one person
who was probably insignificant i
wouldn't i wouldn't because she did
that's that that was the difference so
she did say
if it was a side chick like having a
relationship on the side you'd still be
speaking to them
oh sorry if it wasn't a one-night stand
if it was a one-night stand
or
a relationship over a period of time is
that both acceptable
yeah
okay and would you think if
if he does cheat on you would you think
that he still loves you yeah i would i
don't i don't think i don't i don't
think a man cheating means he doesn't
love his his partner agreed because i
think i think
not to be controversial but monogamy is
a social construct yeah which isn't bad
it's you know it it works for our
society and it's very much if without a
societal conscious social construct we
would do what we want we would do as we
please we brought right back down to our
biology exactly the twenty percent will
get the eighty percent mm-hmm so because
we have to stay with one age we always
get a percentage the more no no because
we're not because we have to stay with
one woman in in the west it enables more
men to have a woman if if they had
polygamy yeah the best men would get the
best wives
but the
i mean
i mean i do i do i do think men are
biologically predispositioned to cheap
but i also think you can make choices to
not put yourself in those situations
yeah um so i i kind of i kind of
understand what both of you guys are
saying because i one hand i really do
think
a lot of guys if it's thrown at them are
going to have a really hard time turning
it down and there's going to be a very
like like tiger woods i think of right
he he had that whole
he had like facebook groups full of
women right and then like that man was
wilden but but like most guys don't have
a a bus full of brazilian models waiting
for them at the end of a golf course i
think most men couldn't turn that down
but at the same time like my dad never
cheated on my mom right and he's in a
top half a percent of earners but he
just doesn't drink and doesn't put
himself in those situations
so i know i was very good at it i don't
think just because you're biologically
predisposed to to cheat
or to be
polygamous i don't
i don't think that means you need to act
on it what i would say as an example
is if
it's it's
men are biologically predispositioned to
violence far more than women okay
now if a man starts to bat the [ __ ] out
of somebody in the street what's the
first thing we'd all say
why couldn't you control yourself yeah
right so i think you can also apply it
to this i think
this is going to piss a lot of men off
i'm sorry but the truth of the matter is
yes i will agree you are biologically
predispositioned to to have more than
one woman or seek out more than one
woman spread your seed so to call it
right that doesn't mean you need to act
on it and i think as a man you can
truly be happy long term without acting
on it
i think you can i should just say one
but it is
a bit controversial go ahead like it's
men are more loyal to their friends than
they are they're women sometimes
men men will not sleep with her friends
if if men
will say i'm not sleeping with a girl
that's been with their friend or that's
a friend's ex it's not lawyers
but they'll sleep around behind the
woman they're supposed to love more than
anything's back like no no the reason
why i don't sleep with my friends with
the girl that's been with my friend is
because i don't like i don't want
no i'm not saying the woman that's
slipped around i'm saying if your friend
was in a relationship with a girl or
like someone your friend not even a
relationship say your friend had fancied
a girl who liked a girl and had told you
you probably wouldn't go there because
of your friend but what i'm saying to
you is you will go behind you will sleep
out of your marital beds but that's not
that's not because because men show
loyalty to women in different ways yep
and so so them is protection and
provisioning that's like that's how they
show loyalty okay and so you're put
you're protecting they're not protected
by sleep it's sleeping right that's not
very good no no no no
it's resources right there they're not
perfect
and protection so if someone breaks into
your house who's expected to go
go fight the robber or whatever it is
that's protection but if with their
friends like they don't get their
protection and provisioning yeah you're
judging us by the woman's measuring
stick yeah
i don't think that means men are more
loyal to their friends than their
partners we as men we provide a
different set of values for you so
though a man may cheat
the values that he is providing to you
again
it all goes back to
the way we are on a biological level
this isn't agreed upon by most people
from what i've seen yeah
but the science is very clear that we
are all
still our brains are still ancient
that's just the truth of matter so if
you're gonna act out of impulse that's a
biological impulse and your brain the
decisions that you make the way you
think is actually still very primal so
for a man to look at another woman and
cheat now i'm not saying he has to do it
you can't argue a man for the impulse
for the lust
and i would even go as far as to say
acting on it however the values that he
provides you
are
physical security
now in modern day times
financial security
okay
and
ultimately he can go out and fend for
himself and get all of the resources
needed
i think ultimately women care more about
those traits those qualities that a man
can provide if he used to [ __ ] up and
accidentally sleep with a woman but he
can still provide all of those things
for you i think
and it i think it also does depend on
age right so if you're younger you're
far more likely to go i've got no real
investment in this man fine i can move
on but i've i can see many situations in
my life and we probably all can where
the man
so she's invested in amanda such that
she's now got a house on a mortgage
she's now got many many kids they are
married one slip up i think if women are
deep down honest with themselves they'll
admit that that one slip up i don't
think it does anything
i don't think i don't think it means he
loves me any less it does nothing
i'm saying having a whole other
relationship that's detrimental okay but
that's that's different yeah that is
that is different
a relationship is very different
honestly the older generation still got
through that they did yeah they did i
know so many grandparents that had like
side chicks for a hot minute and i don't
i don't agree with it
but i think they were just kind of built
of a different cloth right
would you would you accept cheating
would i accept cheating i always say if
i had kids it's not about me anymore
because once you have kids you put the
kids first so if i had kids no i i or if
i had kids i would accept it if i
didn't have kids no i'm leaving
on the flip side of that if
if we're accepting
cheating and our children are also
seeing
the aftermath of that
what
it's it's very small well the kids
shouldn't know i mean i i'm sorry but
yeah that's just a responsibility
that's irresponsible to let your kids
know what your marriage problems are
kids kids know a lot and they don't say
so you might you might not necessarily
want your kids to know or even know that
your children know but
you know they're they're not how how
would kids know that he cheated
not necessarily that he cheated but say
for instance
they might know there's fighting
say for instance i was with i was with
my partner and
he cheated and and that
affected me in a way where i was
completely depressed for a whole year
that's going to affect the children
right but you're depressed
yeah but if i'm depressed i can't look
after my children properly well that's a
choice that's your that's yours that's
your problem you're depressed well it's
not it's not it's not a whole problem
because it's effective okay okay but but
you shouldn't let it affect your kids
wait hold on hold on hold on you said
what so if counseling is
is a mental health issue yeah you can't
say oh you shouldn't be depressed that
doesn't make sense i'm saying you can be
sad and you you can be depressed but the
way you act is a choice and you should
be a mother first and put you before and
put your kids before you it's not about
you anymore once you have children but
you could try to put them first but
ultimately sometimes for some people you
can get yeah you can you could get help
but i'm saying that help could take a
whole year that that rebuilding of
yourself could take a whole year or six
months
what's the alternative right because the
alternative is putting your kid at a
statistical disadvantage
there's a there's a single mother to
prison pipeline so if i put my i put the
i put my kid at the disadvantage not the
man that cheated now if yeah where does
the responsibility come back to him
it's who breaks up the home
who leaves
whoever
oh wait a minute yeah hold on yeah but
we also said that in cases of domestic
violence it's different like yeah so
what i'm saying is so
i'm with i've i've told my partner that
i'm gonna have kids with if you cheat
i'm leaving he's decided to cheat on me
and i have left now i've made my kids
become a statistic that's what you're
saying
only if you act a certain way only if
you act a certain way my fault wait let
me explain it okay okay okay i think
i think we can agree common sense right
yeah if you break up your home then you
leave your kids at a statistical
disadvantage yeah but whether it's your
fault but at home
when you get married are there not vows
so therefore if a man then then goes out
and cheats then it's isn't it him that
breaks he's broken no because he's
breaking the contract he didn't leave he
didn't leave the marriage
at a time
ultimately
you are the catalan you're the catalyst
right right but you're putting yourself
before your children as the mother you
are not so you're supposed to love your
kids more than yourself so detail
himself before all of us can can i
quickly ask a question sorry right this
now this is aside from
cheating
if a man was struggling financially
wasn't doing too well with money
he couldn't find a job or he was down in
the dumps and his ability to provide had
now been knocked
if he was to to basically just sit
around and mope and act all depressed
what would you say to him
i'm gonna help you get up and get back
on your feet and get back maybe in the
beginning but as time goes a minute ago
your example was for a year if i'm
depressed does he have a year to be
depressed and not get [ __ ] done you
would now turn around and look at him
and go bollocks to that your feelings
come second to us and the kids and what
goes on in the household in the security
i think i think that is a massive double
standard i think that example is a bit
different yeah because the guy loses his
job outside of outside but i did state
from the beginning that he is aside from
the thing but
ultimately where it's the same principle
it's one minute i'm depressed and i'm
putting that on my kids and they're
suffering and if a man is depressed and
he's putting out on the kids and now the
wife and the kids are suffering her
her attitude is you need to man up and
get on with it so why as a woman can you
not put it aside and just get on with it
why do the kids have to suffer
for me personally it's easy for you to
say that but if if i was in a position
where my partner cheated on me however
that affects me it can affect me forever
long i can't i would i would hate for
somebody to say put that aside for the
because of the kids in the woman's sake
i would argue i would absolutely argue
it's because they are far more emotional
either way either it's natural it's it's
easy for you to do something to hurt
somebody and say i'll get over it for
because of the kids i feel like that i
understand where you're coming from but
if you're the one causing that pain you
can't then be the same one saying get
over it but you but you but you can mask
it to the point where the kids don't
need to suffer in both cases
that's what i'm saying i'm saying it's
about the kids it's not about your
personal feelings it's about your
children yeah so
can i just clarify that
so we've got married
you know if you cheat that i can't
cannot stay with you because it will
kill me inside it'll make me
whatever oh my god terrible
so you cheat we have kids you cheat
it it is selfish to cheat no no i know
what you're saying so
he's cheated i i haven't done anything
i'm at home playing with my kid with our
kids okay i've done something so he's
cheated but and then
shut up if i leave
it's my fault okay who's whose feelings
are more important the kids are you
everyone's no whose feelings are more
important because me and the kids that's
that he does not matter
who's whose feelings are more important
the kids are you
it has to be the kids okay okay so say i
let it go once then for the kids what
happens if you choose again
the same question still posted no way
are you kidding me that i have to stay
here no no no no no no no
i'm not holding on for nothing i've got
the car keys i'm out of there hold on
sorry all right so every month yeah a
woman has a period yeah yeah
as men
we deal with this
oh oh please i have not even wait let me
land bro i'm sitting in the air like
what my man said let me laugh
hold on
you see this this this is what this this
is so hard for a man to explain because
all right do you go through periods
every month yeah do you chemically
change every month yes are you
emotionally unstable every month
yes
be honest but we have to be honest we
can't just we can't generally speak into
the mic we can't generalize i've had
many girlfriends many links many were
just as you have but in my personal
experience they've never treated me
differently or acted differently to a
point where i can say you're emotionally
unbalanced because you're on your period
to me i'm not saying it doesn't happen
i'm not saying it doesn't happen but in
my experience in general why are you
shaking your hand
he said not in general but we're dealing
with generals hold on
what you got
on the cheating topic right
i'm saying we just need to be honest
right if i'm in a marriage and my wife
takes a penis in her vagina and i leave
i can't be the one to blame for breaking
the would you take would you carry the
blame if your wife cheated and you and
you divorced just that yes do you want
me to answer the question before i've
even landed on my main point oh sorry i
mean i don't know
get back to my main point here but it
really shifted so because your you don't
have a period so you wouldn't know if a
woman has an emotional i mean a um would
you call it a a different chemical
experience from a period yeah which they
release a hormone yeah which makes them
chemically different
that okay you don't that doesn't change
that's facts yeah i'm not challenged all
right so i'm saying
that yeah so i'm saying as a man
when a woman goes through that certain
time of the month yeah we are
conditioned to kind of
adjust navigate
her feelings yeah
so a woman in her brain does understand
that a certain time a chemical changes
in her head where she does not act
normal
but yet she can't understand the same
chemical not the same chemical but the
same
chemical reaction happens in a man where
he can't control but you can
control
you can control because when you're at
work and you're in your period plan you
could be very nice to your boss but as
soon as you come home to your husband
it's like
it's like no no you know you don't have
to control it wait wait wait what i'm
saying
where are you getting that from yeah i
don't know where you're getting that
information which part of the
information if
if i'm on one i'm on one everywhere like
no no one is is like everyone so you're
trying to tell me if you wanna if you're
on your period and you're feeling very
irritable you're gonna take it out on
your manager 100
come on man is that
right is that the average
okay okay you don't know how to control
your emotions at work
i i don't have to if i if i if i don't
want to i won't
i don't know man
i feel like it's incomparable i feel
like i feel like the concept of me the
concept of a person feeling hurt because
you've broken the marital vows
and in in comparison to
and and and
her being put in a condition where we're
telling her to deal with it in
comparison to a man dealing with his
partner on her period is very they're
very difficult
the question please about em if
so the marriage is there
we're all happy families and i've went
out yeah and i've cheated
so you're going to stay with me no
that's right
hold on hold on
the feelings of the kids first don't you
as a man one at a time guys
so all i'm trying to say is on a human
level right everybody would be hurt if
i'm in a marriage my wife doesn't
doesn't have to have sex if she kisses a
guy if she sucks his dick and i know and
i leave do you think i'm going to accept
from society that i'm the one who
brought
anyone who says that
be
okay first of all if your wife sucks
another man's dick yeah what are you
doing staying or leaving
well
no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no
i'm leaving
guys guys it has to be one at a time
we've got away from something as a man
you can leave
and the kids can still not suffer
because if the woman has cheated and the
man leaves yeah how she conducts herself
and how the man conducts himself around
the kids will be what dictates whether
the kids suffer or not it's not about
whether you leave or how she treats the
kids afterwards or how she is around the
kids whether she's her i agree but the
topic was based on the woman dealing
with the effects of the manchester and
the blame being on her if she acts
differently so on that same topic if you
act differently if your wife has had
another man's dick in her mouth
naturally you would there's no there's
no man right here it's completely
different
let me explain to you why my brother
first of all yeah more than likely
you're the person going down on one knee
so you have decided that a that's my
wife right yeah she could wait until
kingdom come for you to go down on me
and you don't have to go down on me
right yeah so that means you've
committed to her yeah yeah right and
she's accepted your commitment yeah yeah
knowing who you are and she knows what a
man is like already she knows you're a
predisposition yeah correct or no yeah
right so when you act out on that
predisposition that she already knows of
she is already calculating in her head
the way out of it
because she's already hypergamous so i'm
going for a rich man knowing that he's
going to cheat
knowing that i'm going to take him for
half his stop no no no okay hold on
hold on yeah i know that i'm going to
i'm going to go with a man that's highly
likely going to cheat correct or no not
necessarily ask these girls and they
will tell you highly likely a man is
going to cheat or a man is thinking
about cheating so it's hard
when the woman is saying yes i do or yes
i i do want to marry she's already
considering that one
wait i i agree with him in this in the
point that a woman will know the type of
value man she's getting with has the
ability
to exercise his options i don't know
what she hold on everybody knows that
so
yeah she's weighed up a risk
as to whether
this is possible now here's my here's my
point if not if i'm getting married to
rihanna i'm weighing up my risk are you
gonna marry a whole of course i'm not
going to marry you right so but she's
going to marry a holder
yeah right she's not basically hold on
hold on look think of that understanding
you're not going to marry a whole yeah
she would marry your whole and that's
the difference
guys man okay let's say that's that's
the case but you can't eliminate human
emotion and human reasoning of course
you can't say because you knew he's a
man and he's not naturally monogamous
it's you should have known that there
was a high chance of this is ridiculous
like
listen guys you have a son and you have
a daughter
the in the exact same situation the guy
the daughter's husband cheats the son's
wife cheats it doesn't matter who's a
male or who knew what you're both
feeling for you're feeling for them
equally regardless of the whether one's
a male ones are feet like
giving them i'm giving them different
advice though yeah of course but i'm
saying you're removing the human
reaction just a natural response but but
we're not taught like
it's just why are you bringing the
emotion into it no because like because
we're talking
no because the whole thing like it's
just like i feel like i'm a girl like
why are you bringing this into it
obviously obviously they're going to
have an emotional reaction
you guys are overlooking the emotional
reaction and saying it's the woman the
woman is to blame for breaking up yes
i'm saying women leave 70 to 80 of the
time 90 of their college educated and
i'm saying women put their feelings
before their own kids
you knew you married dude you knew he
might cheat on you then he cheats on you
and then boo hoo poor me i need to break
up the home and put put my feelings
before my kids you know who you marry i
agree but what equally what i'm saying
is if that happens to a man the man
would leave the marriage equally whether
i knew she was going to whether i didn't
know all those things are just do you
think men and women are the same
no okay so you see you understand why
they're different you're fifty percent
there so
we just lost your job would you leave
her
no right but many women would leave
their men because they lost their
hundred percent correct because the
women are different what they what they
what would keep them in a relationship
is different to what would keep us in a
relationship
yes yes you're a cheerleader man ish you
are the biggest cheerleader
but i'm a lion though
so you change your mind then nobody has
changed no yes it changes by
i'm saying to you yeah
if i'm going to her she already knows
i'm promiscuous yeah
she's already saying listen if he's
promiscuous he better be the best man
that i could get yeah the best
promiscuous man that i could get because
i'm already dealing with the
consequences whether or not i go with a
broke guy he's going to achieve if i go
a rich guy is going to be i'm as we'll
go with a rich guy
yeah
yeah yeah so yeah i'm already taken out
of the relationship what i want to i'm
telling her what i'm willing to accept
there's certain things in the
relationship that men are willing to
accept that a woman would never accept
in a relationship so you think it's
perfectly fine
for me to get married all right go and
cheat come back and say dude know i
think it's perfectly fine for you to
have two wives if you want to have more
than one wife okay
what do you mean okay what like what
first of all because that's a separate
topic because marriage to me is that's
polygamy sorry yeah i just want to say
that i've been dating all wrong like
i've just realized
obviously that tends to happen with red
pool yeah your eyes open what is red
pill no i'm just saying from the advice
i'm getting from you guys you like you
and the cheerleader yeah and this isn't
expensive
no experience love doesn't exist and
we've just got to deal with what we get
and you know i think no no it's like
yeah
life is about trade-offs if you want a
guy in the top 10 20 he might cheat and
if he does don't be surprised would you
would you agree that you go for a guy
would you agree that you go for a go at
the top level knowing that there is a
higher chance it will cheat because he's
pre-selected other people are going to
want if he's at the top level you're
interested in him the likelihood is
other women are going to be i mean look
at it so do you agree that you women
love other people's men
yeah so marry an average guy that no
other girl look looks at yeah then you
won't have that problem mm-hmm okay yeah
or have a little then you'll be bored
and you won't stay with him you're
likely cheap so
like paul said it's a trade-off like
every area okay so i'm either going for
the top 20
and they're going to cheat on me like
i'm going for the other 80
and now i'm gonna cheat it's a no-win
situation
let them go statistics what do we see
with what
if if 20 percent of the women go for 100
percent of the men okay 100 percent of
when we go for 20. so yeah yeah
what's the statistic and cheating that
the man will cheat
if he is in the top 20. okay it's um
so basically it's pretty equal when it
comes to cheating it's about one out of
four admit to cheating when asked right
and we can all probably attest that it
might be a little higher because people
don't always admit to it but then if you
get a guy that makes over 250 000 per
year it ups to 50 so 50 of men that make
over 250 thousand dollars per year it
doesn't mean all my dad didn't cheat
yeah it doesn't mean yeah and so that's
what we know of some yeah that's true
that's true um
is there a statistic
is there is there a statistic on
women who go for
average guys
or below the high level guys is there a
statistic on how many times these women
cheat
no i don't know actually because from my
personal experience
i can count on one hand right now how
many people i know women i know are
cheating on their husbands right this
very second and they have average men
and if they were with a top-tier man
they also equally understand that's just
ones i know right now i'm talking i've
never talked about in the past right but
they also admit that if they were the
top level guy they would accept him
cheating yeah i mean i think those girls
couldn't get the guys that they wanted
so they settled so they are a little bit
older yeah so they settled so they
couldn't get kids and then they cheat
with the guy they actually wanted and
sometimes they
i've seen some
numbers and i'm not sure how accurate
this is but up to like 20 25 percent of
guys are raising a kid that's not theirs
wow so can i ask you guys yeah ladies
yeah if your best friend was cheating on
her partner would you tell her partner
no exactly thank you you see what i'm
trying to say you are so deceiving yeah
wait no you've got to break it down
that's not my business that's not
that's not i i don't think i'm declaring
anyone's cheating on you so why would
you go out of your way
like that no i've done it
do you know what i found
i find
um
you'll be the bad guy so if you if you
found out her her man was cheating on
her would you tell her
next thing would you tell your friend if
you found out her man yeah right so do
you understand the same thing with guys
but that's that's because that's because
you're friends with one yeah yeah yeah
my point to that is this yeah
we already know what it's like because
we accept what it's like they don't
accept what it's like bro so you're
saying yeah but it's like that for guys
yeah i know because we accept it for
guys but they don't accept it for women
you don't you don't want your man to
cheat but you're not gonna tell
um your your
your best friend's partner if your
friend's cheating on her and you're not
going to and you're going to tell you're
going to tell her if her man's cheating
okay would you honestly round with you
turn it around would you tell your best
friend that his missus was cheating yeah
of course
your best friend's misses that he was
cheating depends you wouldn't oh give me
a break about it it doesn't depends
because i have and i haven't before
oh you've actually got your best friend
you tell his missus is cheating i have
and i have before yes why are you
telling her because it's acceptable
yeah if it's like honestly
i'm with you i've been on both sides at
like different points yeah depends upon
the friendships
it's just what you said you said
yeah depends how how i see how the girl
is if the girl is the sweet one yeah
she's a loyal one she's a loyal one yeah
she's a decent girl you come from a
decent family and you're doing all of
that matting i'm like bro you can't do
that no naturally you will talk to your
mother
what's natural to cheat
for men to cheat it's it's it's but this
is what i was saying earlier is that
if it is natural to cheat but if you can
and if you're dating the top 20 percent
and you marry them and you have kids
with them then i think it's also down to
you as a woman to be
a woman that they want to be loyal to so
you are having sex with him you're not
holding it as no i hate so
if he cheated on you would you would you
leave him
now now have you got kids i haven't got
kids no so without the kids you would
leave yeah but after the kid you would
stay with him yeah
um
yes i would
because i'll be putting the kids first
but if it was like a but if you if she
cheats speaking to the microphone if she
cheats would you leave
i wouldn't stay with any woman who
cheated on me
and i never have i love this i love this
and it depends on what time i'm right
now you're assuming that men and women
are the same we aren't the same our
biologists
i'm not saying we're the same but i'm
saying loyalty are like can we not have
the same loyalty so so i'll ask you a
question outside of body count and
cheating right name one double standard
that does not benefit women
there's not one don't worry about it
let's move on
it's just why are you there man getting
your camera
i like that i like that and does that
even benefit men because you're helping
out another broke girl you know i mean
like me having me helping out two girls
that have been hypergamous i'm lifting
both of them out of poverty
so i'm more for women than you think
do you have money like that
but you're the one telling your best
friend's misses that he's cheating
you're just sitting there saying but i'm
sorry i'm so confused yeah he's no good
man
it must be wrong in that one you're a
hater no
no because you're unless you're gonna
get her yeah
let me cheat on you
on you him cheating no let me cheat on
you but that's what i'm saying like the
world benefits women sorry do you cheat
in relationships normally
i'm coming for you
do i cheat what do you consider cheating
right now no no no no no no no
stop it listen
before we get into relationship we're
already having the conversation of you
already know gel lemma on the
the guy so
i don't have to say listen babes i'm
going to cheat on you but i'm going to
say listen it's going to be highly like
i'm going to try not to say i'm asking
you in previous relationships have you
do most in most of your relationships
have you cheated
out of all of your relationships how
many say you've had say you had six
relationships what's the ratio of your
cheating
okay so the what what made me not cheat
was what
wasn't the question no no no no no no no
no no no no all right look at it
do you cheat i think it is
circumstantial and i can i can give you
yes or no i don't know i can give you i
want to hear this yes
at the end of the day i do i do believe
to an extent well no i do believe
outright that it's true once a year
always a cheater for both men and women
right but
the longest relationship i've had
is with the goal to my left that's three
years uh-huh right i've never cheated on
have no intentions to but
i have cheated multiple times in
relationships that lasted far longer i
do truly believe it it depends on your
state of mind
how old you are and you learn your
priorities you learn your experience and
this is this is key it depends on the
type of woman she is i hear you
ultimately so i believe technically
speaking to ask the question do you
cheat it's like
do you drink capri suns or do you drink
coke it's like different times in a
[ __ ] year like it's just a silly
question
am i missing something here
am i the only one that doesn't know this
are you not together
yeah
yeah you missed that
wow
you're really observant aren't you
you knew it as well yeah
i think i think i think everyone knew
that that's the only time
the last time i checked that was anyway
yeah oh this this is very interesting
then
yeah
so
how long are you
three years did you listen three years
oh my god
why are you gonna get married to her
yeah
are you what's stopping you right now
it's a good question it's a good
question come on let's come on we don't
need the ring why not no why not now and
not four years down the line like always
like
three years come on man you're coming
money
the career position i mean because as
soon as i get married we're going to
have kids immediately
that's my ultimate reason why expensive
to get married i don't think that's an
excuse
i'm
so i'm i'm just curious you could just
go to the courthouse and get married is
that is a wedding necessary is that
something that you really want i didn't
we
because we've we've discussed it and
we've even discussed um just changing my
last name speaking to them i'm sorry
um
yeah we've just discussed just changing
the last name and not even going through
like the formal yeah
yeah i should actually stress that when
when you ask me will i marry her
when i said yes what i actually mean is
she'll get her last name changed and
we will be together until the day we die
that's how certain we feel i don't
really feel the need for the government
to be involved in where the [ __ ] my [ __ ]
goes
or our relationship at all
personally i don't take you seriously no
more bro no but i
together all this time throughout all
that discussion
yeah
oh my god so i'm not a big fan i'm not a
big fan of america
i'm not a big fan of marriage these like
walked in like they're not walking
together they're like holding
but neither one of us are a big fan of
marriage but we're more certain of being
together long term than most people who
get married are so eat so okay how are
you what you have kids right no no you
haven't got kids nope
do you you want kids yep
how old are you 24. 24.
it's making sense now so that's that's
why he was kind of trembling so
[Laughter]
so you'd allow him to cheat if you had
kids no
no no no no she never said allow
she would stay would you
stay
for the children it doesn't mean she'd
stay with me but she would
she wouldn't she wouldn't break up
what we have for the sake of the kids
that's probably what you would
wait what was that
what was that she said
you guys seem jealous
i will say i will say we we have
something a lot of people don't i can
say right no no no no no no no that's
right yeah
i sat here what did i say to you i was
like speaking to them
i i love love give me love every day i'm
not jealous but
i don't
like when she said about the cheating
thing
i thought wow
i was kind of disappointed i'm not gonna
lie i was like
you're already saying that's
unacceptable
she would she i know for a fact that she
would leave me if i cheated but i'm also
smart enough to not cheat if i if i say
i love her and i honestly love her
it may be this
this is something that people probably
won't agree with but for me
if he if we had a family if we had three
kids and we were married and we had been
together 20 years and then he cheated i
would think
i've what have i done
what have i done do you realize that
when a man cheats it's not necessarily
anything to do with you yeah yeah it's
nothing to do with you exactly
women really need to understand that
it's but i i believe that i've found
someone that isn't stupid enough to
cheat and don't hear that and that's
great that's right you also have the
value right like you bringing the value
to like when you're so you're so pretty
and you're so sweet you know like i can
tell you're so feminine just like when
you walked in
and like you you have the value to ask
that of a guy
yeah and i think women should be more
straight up yeah with themselves that's
why i realize what they are bringing to
the relationship
they're always asking for their list
and they're not actually at that
standard themselves they need it
yeah and that's what i'm saying like you
have the leverage of youth right you're
only 24 and like you're pretty and so
and so you have and you're in shape but
a lot of girls don't have those three
things and they're still asking for they
need to work on it yeah and then
and i'm very aware that i'm not going to
have that for very long so when when i'm
older over the hill
i'm i'm i'm going to want him to stick
around and why is he going to stick
around with someone that's older when he
could men get better when they're older
you know but they're still going to be
attracting 19 year olds so i need to
give them a reason to not cheat can i
always figure out the game
can i can i also just stress
contrary to what you see couples do
pretty much 99 at a time
before we got together
so we we was good friends because we
both worked with each other right and i
got us both fired i just thought i'd
throw that out there where did you where
how the hell did you get
rebel
rebel from day one um so which gym we
were we were good friends yeah
don't say absolutely
don't say it
[ __ ] it banner time hey
um yeah so let them back we were yeah
no so so we we were good friends
and friends as colleagues for a good
half a year before we actually got
together and we knew a lot about our own
values before we even got together so
when we did get together it was a
calculated decision based on everything
that we'd
taken on board
she she knew me fully i knew her fully
there was no there was no real i'm gonna
get to know you process once we got
together that was already there the
decision was made based on everything we
need to know about each other and i
think that is something that
i'm not no i'm not going to say that
people need to do that like typically
speaking but in our circumstance that's
the way it went and that's why we're we
were so certain in the beginning and
we're just a certain now and we'll be
just a certain in 20 34 years
the only thing that's what i'm saying
when you're saying about we sound
jealous when we was fighting the only
thing i didn't it was the only thing was
that referring to you i can't lie oh no
no that's fine but i i just wanted for
everyone what the only thing that i know
the only thing not even annoyed me that
got my back was like when you said you
would accept it even from the off i
wanted you to have said no i won't
accept it i know i know what you're
saying to have a family but
i felt like i kind of get what you're
saying because i call cat because i'm
like wait now that i know you're a lot
together i don't want you lot here on
the same show talking about that's kind
of what i've asked you that when you
want to sit like separately
because it's how strong their
relationship
is one at a time
i do see where you're coming from i do
see where you're coming from and all i
can say is
we we know truly how we feel i don't
expect you to believe that you don't
know us either one of us from adam i get
that but there's unfortunately nothing i
can do to help you that's like i do
fully understand where you're coming
from i think you say i i can i i can
only ask that you believe us when we say
what we say but i can't i can't force
you to because
the pinch of salt on top is not
necessarily your lion it's
you don't know what what the other
person is like when you're not there
right here's
here's here's what i will say right now
obviously i can't prove this right now i
know that but if you used to speak to
anybody i'll speak to personally he
doesn't speak to her about it and vice
versa they all say the same thing not
exactly what we're saying never i don't
think it's right to challenge what you
got yeah yeah no no but it's a good
point it's a valid point so what what
attracted you to him
and
he's a high-value man yeah
right
he is um so he was very
protected protective of me
um he
went like like he said when we first met
we were colleagues so there was
straight away there wasn't the we didn't
go on a date so there wasn't the um
[Music]
like intention there wasn't like that
awkwardness of like right what can i get
out of you
in an exchange there was no exchange it
was just like you're
there
and um so i was able to
find out what he wanted and
yeah there were there was many things um
the confidence
um
how damn good-looking he is
i am happy
so
do you what do you still is that what
keeps you there now though
what keeps me there
is
knowing
knowing that he's loyal to me
knowing that he has respect for himself
and respect for me
um what's here what's your hold up
see because now i'm calling catcall man
i'm calling my cat
i wish
put your fingers in your air like i
don't want it to like what's keep what's
keeping your here in this relationship
be honest
what's keeping him in the relationship
no what's keeping her in the room why
are you saying that
okay i could ask you could ask your mark
you're jealous but are you jealous i
want a good weight
in a good way okay of course three years
together i'm rating that like anyone
that's in the relationship can i just
say something but can i just say
something
i know
so damn much
about game
understanding female nature
that
i'm
i've done all the work i need to to make
myself
the type of man that a woman would be
proud to be with for one
and two
i where i understand female nature so
damn well
i have been able to get a lot out of my
system and she knows that which means i
now know what i want so i don't feel
like i'm going through the
trying to figure you out process
i now know exactly what i want in her
she just she just she's just it
and the process that i was coming
through
when we first got together just before
we got together i was very upfront with
her in the beginning that i wasn't
actually wanting to settle down with
anybody i wanted to just essentially
keep sleeping around she would tell me
that herself
but there's certain things that she
offered me and she demonstrated that
i couldn't refuse now this is this no no
this this is on top of the fact that i
was essentially now getting bored with
the nightlife that sort of scene
i knew exactly what i wanted in a woman
and she demonstrated every single one of
them that i wanted and like i said it's
been three years
we are just as happy
just as certain and secure in each other
than we was day one and i think
the reason we're in that position is
because we've done the work prior to
getting to know each other we've done a
lot of deep work
yeah man i do kind of jealousy
relationship i rate it
um okay i'm gonna read super chats for a
second
um okay let me
also guys all these super chats as you
guys know are going towards getting ish
a camera on top of that guys sign up for
our memberships okay for real because
you will get exclusive behind-the-scenes
content we are releasing a vlog this
week ish lost the bet he had to take me
and jess to dinner
fun times
yeah we ordered everything on the menu
so it's pretty cool genuinely yeah
okay um so 90 free topay pearl you have
to watch patrice o'neill black philip ep
1 through 13. the women here talk the
same way as women from 2005 regarding
relationships
aquare's kicks umpire um you sent an
emoji alastar horden a harsh truth is
better than a sweet lie
house of has
wvm she and girlfriends help them hide
it real friends question mark 90 free
toe pay
cheating is different for us men cheat
just to get the juice out women cheap
because they like the guy i'm 90 free
chope cute dress pearl when you ask a
female a question have them repeat it to
you and see what one watch what happens
vic quinoas modern women don't have high
standards they have double standards the
uk economist the whole topic of cheating
seems immature monogamy is the best
structure for children and families ob1
classic i'm sorry i'm not able to follow
this right now it's just very simple
don't cheat save yourself the headache
to begin with corey women in black is a
perfect example is the problem modern
women put their needs and feelings at an
equal if not greater level than their
kids that women's rebuttal is was how
she felt kids are irrelevant robert m
fat guys tend to be sensitive honest
citizen adam and eve means monogamy is
the ideal adam chose eve over god
a man's weaknesses to sex eve chose the
apple to which to is to have a higher
status than god desire for excess sex
and marriage and or marital are both bad
yin yang what if the woman cheats back
lincoln ward men's biological impulses
to sleep around is the same as a woman's
urge to find the top mating option
available yet only one is viewed
negatively sentience to the lady in red
if you would drop a man who gave you
gave into his nature of spreading his
seed should a man drop you if you will
seek attention and validation out of his
attention alone since the woman's nature
to seek attention robert m young
beautiful chaste female coachable
jc taurus white boy on point he's
spitting facts trevor lane the thumb has
great points props
miss um a mescilla lester of two evil
sleeping around doesn't benefit women or
mana devalues the meaning of
relationships and ruins relationships
with baggage um fudge knuckle elon or
any man as
are versus a woman who passed birthing
her first kit first fifth kid in her 20s
who makes a bigger difference in the
world after 50 years sentience to the
woman who said
who said about the woman's highlight in
her in her living room question if women
crave attention which attention most
would most women prefer unbashed
superficial attention or attention from
a loving family who adores you kaiser co
girl in red would be a platinum level
woman if she believed these things
bretnam schaefer without a child in your
life you will eventually be less
fulfilled i'm 49 with no child and it
used to be fun but now it's just profile
and sad um
lazarus the standards are too high when
she said she expects men to be in a tax
bracket that they can't even reach
jeremy a which man would the female
guest rather have a high value man with
little time for a relationship or an
average man with lots of time for a
relationship trevor lane camo and red
shirt are absolute dimes david you gren
gyuk just got here what did i miss road
rhodes 688 woman
um emoji what adam represented to eve
digital sparks betta white had a
sweating oh wait i think i did that one
already let me refresh the page
and just make sure there aren't any more
um
also guys like the video it really helps
with the algorithm i think there's 3 000
people in here there should be
at least a thousand two hundred likes
okay you're at a thousand one hundred
now help a girl out okay
um
the uk economist if the lady in the red
met a millionaire would you leave her
current partner for him this is the
question everyone is wondering project
utopian this comes with bias
unacceptable to have partners on a show
pearl reel what happened to your iq what
the all right whatever um
see see
i read it that's what i'm saying they
come from me sometimes too they come
from they said what happened to your iq
um
um kazumu green pants is saying red
shirt is out of his league she must have
something else going on 90 free top
you put pearl you have to i read that
one already okay well i think i'm going
to close out the show um i think this is
actually a really fun show and i really
appreciated everyone going back and
forth i thought it was a lot of fun so
to
end the show we're going to go around
everyone you can give any final thoughts
that you have you want to tell the
people and tell them where they can find
you
so like social media handles whatever so
you can start um i think it was a cool
show everybody had valid
and contradictory and controversial
thoughts including myself um you can
find me on instagram candyfloss
chocolate muffin
y'all speaking to the mike say that
again you can find me on instagram uh
candyfloss chocolate muffin hey spell it
c-a-n-d-double-i dot floss dot chocolate
dot muffin see the dot you missed it
brilliant
go ahead um yeah i had a really good
time um
i'm not really a big talker but i really
enjoyed everyone else's opinions and i
actually learned a lot as well so that
was good uh you can find me on i am
pillow talks on instagram and
pillowtalkstv on youtube
and i had a great time i've also learned
a few gems
and i think you're all great i think um
it was a really good vibe you can find
me on instagram
at diazdon
and yeah thank you for having us yeah
thank you for coming god yeah that was
really fun um
i don't actually have instagram
um
yeah
yeah the chat is gonna go crazy
is she real
is she really
she's the real deal
so yeah names uh instagram jordan fuller
official
final thoughts
men women do the work
look at the science work on yourselves
that's really all i can say
and um
it ain't white boy it's vanilla gorilla
yeah yeah yeah
yeah like that okay yes sorry
um yeah
i'm just trying to appeal to
lonelyguy357
leave only fans alone
send some money to paul so we could get
ish a camera
send that subscriber to 150 to 160 like
stop playing around like i'm here on
this you know where i am so sub to this
channel
um i would also like to say um we passed
a really important milestone this stream
we had three thousand live viewers which
is the most viewed we have ever had on a
stream
um guys thank you so much all of the
donations all of the likes the comments
are really important to growing the
channel i really appreciate all of you i
also want to shout out oscar mc
he just sent a super chat so i'm gonna
shout him out too
but okay guys like the video on your way
out subscribe to the channel because if
you don't we have beef and i will talk
to you next time
and that's a wrap